the federal indictments against Donald
Trump have just been issued he is being
charged over false claims about the 2020
election particularly his effort to
overturn the results and the lead-up to
the obstruction of official proceedings
we'll go through the I believe there's
four counts here but this is it they're
saying that Donald Trump was engaged in
a conspiracy essentially against the
United States we're also hearing there
will be likely another indictment coming
out of Georgia with potentially more
than a dozen defendants there are also
several unindicted co-conspirators in
this charge ladies and gentlemen this is
probably the most serious effort taken
by Biden's doj explicitly to interfere
in the 2024 election to prevent Trump
from winning we've heard a lot of people
say that Trump can't win they talk about
polls but the polls are actually showing
Donald Trump is doing better than ever
and that he's either tied with or
beating Joe Biden so what is Joe Biden
doing exactly this now of course you can
argue it's Merrick Garland it's the doj
but these are Joe oh Biden's appointees
and they are going after the front
runner for the Republican Party
it's unprecedented and I think it is
rather terrifying where this goes we're
going to break down this story and much
more we also have big news coming out of
Russia another drone strike on Targets
in Moscow and now we're seeing more and
more calls to bring back the military
draft I'm not kidding military.com just
published an op-ed saying that we need a
limited Military draft Joe Biden just
called the select reserves and the ready
reserves the likelihood of a military
draft in the event of a full-scale war
well it's there it's there
so we're going to talk about this and a
lot more before we do my friends head
over to castbrew.com and buy cast Brew
Coffee to support the show gas Brew is
our coffee company so casper.com has the
cast Brew Coffee Club you sign up you
get three bags per month we've also got
Appalachian nights our dark roast it's
the best coffee I've ever had I got to
be honest rise with Roberto Jr light
roast and of course Mr boccus pumpkin
spice experience take a look at that one
also don't forget to head over to
timcast.com click join us to become a
member and support the show directly
we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show coming up for you at
about 10 p.m we do this Monday through
Thursday you don't want to miss it as a
member you are helping support our work
directly so that we can do more shows
like this hire people so if you really
do like the work we're doing please
consider supporting us but also just
more importantly share the show right
now take the URL post it wherever you
can it's the most powerful way to help
the the work we do podcasts growth or
word of mouth so again smash that like
button share the show with your friends
joining us today to talk about this in a
whole lot more is Taylor Hansen nice to
be here who are you what do you do I'm
an independent journalist and field
reporter um you know I cover a little
bit of everything from Child drag shows
to you know was the riots January 6th
but you know we like to cover a little
bit of everything right on well thanks
for hanging out it should be interesting
we also got Phil Labonte how you doing
everybody I am philibonti lead singer of
the heavy metal band All That Remains
anti-communist and uh
counter-revolutionary right Ian Crossing
what's up everybody let's get rolling
yeah I am surge.com I agree let us go oh
that was fast let's jump into this first
story here we have some of the AP
Trump indicted for efforts to overturn
2020 election and block transfer of
power
Donald Trump was indebted on felony
charges Tuesday for working to overturn
the results of the 2020 election in the
run-up to the violent Riot by his
supporters at the U.S Capitol with the
doj moving to hold him accountable for
an unprecedented effort to block the
peaceful trance of Presidential Power
the four count indictment the third
criminal case against Trump provided
deeper insight into a dark chapter in
American history that has already been
the subject of exhaustive federal
investigations and captivating public
hearings the Chronicles A month's long
campaign of lies about the election
results and says that even when those
false it's culminated in a chaotic
Insurrection at the Capitol Trump sought
to exploit that Violence by by trying to
further delay the counting of votes that
sealed his defeat they go on to then add
some opinion nonsense we can I think we
have the the actual indictment right
here
count one conspiracy to defraud the U.S
count two conspiracy to obstruct an
official proceeding count three
obstruction of and attempt to obstruct
an official proceeding and conspiracy
against rights
they go on to lay out their case with a
few interesting points I'll pull this
one up from Brett L Tolman who says I've
now read the indictment twice it is
criminalizing speech thought legal uh
legal positions right or wrong and
disinformation it is also shockingly
manipulative of statuses and theories
which acquire enormous legal wrangling
further further it ignores advice of
council defenses ends and men's rare
requirements but the most glaring thing
is what's not in the indictment the
charges of treasonous addition or any
other serious fact-based count outlining
genuinely criminal Behavior the
unindicted co-conspiracies are lawyers
representing the accused a doj employee
and a political consultant and their
conspiracy believing there was election
fraud talking about election fraud and
pursuing legal challenges in States they
believed election of fraud occurred to
put it simply ladies and gentlemen Trump
has been indicted for taking the advice
of lawyers that's it
so I I think the reality is that they're
going to make up whatever reason they
can to go after Donald Trump to prevent
him from running in 2024 they'll likely
use this or whatever comes out of this
because this is going to be a DC jury
the likelihood that Trump gets a fair
trial is nil there's likely going to be
a bunch of Democrats we're going to vote
to indict and when he does they will
move to remove him from the ballots in
2024 for citing the 14th Amendment or
Insurrection or something that effect
yep and I I think that it's not as much
as the you're only going to see the
effect on Trump right now going forward
for the rest of essentially American
history or until there's some kind of
significant change at the in the
bureaucracy in Washington any Outsider
candidate is going to be treated like
Trump now granted Trump gives
gives plenty of ammo to the left to uh
and I think that's that's plenty is an
understanding yeah and I think it's an
understatement but
um the fact remains they are
Prosecuting them or indicting him for
things that he was found not guilty of
with the impeachment in the Senate so he
was tried for a lot of the same things
here in the Senate when he was impeached
and they was found not guilty
it's it's it's the same stuff so they're
they're just like it's it's clear that
they're trying to make him uh either
prevent them from being the uh the
nominee or make it making you know I
think we can't vote for him you know I
think they want him to be the nominee
and then once he is they remove them
from the ballot and now they're
unopposed just cause mass chaos yup well
it seems like they're gonna they're
going down this route regardless like
there's not going to be any end to
indictments if this isn't the indictment
that takes them out there'll be a new
indictment in a month I mean we've seen
it over and over and over again they're
never gonna give this guy a break and
it's interesting to me that they tried
to tie in like January 6 just a little
bit to this even though I mean it's been
proven time and time again there was no
incitement from him you know he
basically had no role in this I mean the
capital was our the capital grounds were
already breached while he was still
speaking and then he released the video
on Twitter Twitter took it down they
took the other video down and they
banned him so Howard his father was
supposed to see him saying you know stay
peaceful we love the Capitol Police we
support the Capitol Police you can't but
they're just never going to stop this it
seems like if I either my original
thoughts was that we're gonna run them
through the ringer find them guilty of
something and then take his name off the
ballot maybe that will happen the other
thing I'm just reading about it people
are like yo he's getting bankrupted and
that may not literally bankrupted but
this is costing him a lot of money I
think it's been I think he spent like
what four I saw something like 40
million dollars and he's being attacked
for it this is what I I never liked
about these duplicitous political
attacks Steve Bannon and that other dude
they're doing that build the wall
campaign they get a bunch of donations
they indict and charge one of the guys
behind it because he said he wouldn't
take a salary and then he did not a
single person who donated a legitimate
fan cared that someone got paid a salary
when they said they weren't going to get
paid they're probably like sure whatever
and this is the same thing here you've
got you've got people saying Donald
Trump is swindling of supporters by
taking the donations to pay his legal
fees
and I'm just like dude not a single
Trump supporter cares what Trump does
with them they know what this money is
going towards like they see the
indictments over and over again and even
if they didn't they're so loyal to Trump
I don't think they're going to care at
all I agree if Trump came out and said
look we took a bunch of the Buddy and we
bought a golden toilet for my plane
every his fans would laugh they'd love
it yeah especially show us pictures like
it feels good when I sit on it they'd be
like yes
it's warm yeah let me read this from the
indictment check this out this is
interesting section three it says page
two the defendant had a right like every
American to speak publicly about the
election and to even claim falsely that
there had been outcome determinative
fraud during the election that he had
won he was also entitled to formally
challenged the results of the election
through lawful and appropriate means
such as by seeking recounts or audits of
the popular vote in states or filing
lawsuit challenging ballots and
procedures indeed in many cases the
defendant did pursue these methods of
contesting the election results his
efforts to change the outcome in any
state through recounts audits or legal
challenges were uniformly unsuccessful
shortly after election day the defendant
also pursued unlawful means of
discounting legitimate votes and
subverting the election results in doing
so the defendant perpetrated three
criminal conspiracies now this is this
is the interesting thing
they just the first one the first
paragraph they're saying or I say I'm
sorry paragraph three that he's allowed
to say these things how to claim these
things he's allowed to seek these
challenges but he also did Eagle illegal
things itself it's not that it's that
they immediately then say but he did
illegal things therefore like okay you
should list those illegal things like if
he's allowed to make these claims if
he's allowed to file these lawsuits if
all that's fine what did he do
well seems like he's being prosecuted
for trying to legally question the
election that's what it really yeah
here's what they say a conspiracy to
defraud the U.S using dishonesty fraud
and deceit to impair obstruct and defeat
the lawful federal government function
by which the results of the presidential
election are collected quite literally
saying Trump's allowed to be wrong but
he's not allowed to be wrong he's not
allowed to lie he's allowed to be wrong
but he's not allowed to lie and say it
if he knows that it's not true every
fiber of Donald Trump's being believes
that he won the presidency like every
single bit of Donald Trump you know
what's interesting this indictment comes
out too and then he got the DeSantis
Camp releasing something trying to say
like counteract the fact that you know
he actually believed it they're saying
that he knew beforehand that it wasn't
actually stolen so and then it's
interesting that this indictment comes
out and the way that it's worded so it
seems like there might almost be like
working off of each other it's but the
Santa's Camp is clearly trying to take
Trump down and I don't think Trump had
like hard evidence that it was true so
if he made the claim you can't know it
it's true if you don't have evidence the
hard evidence so it would just be an
assumption you can still believe in it
that's not a lie he was just asserting
he was just saying this is the way that
it is I know I'm confident in it the the
IDE I mean there it's reasonable to say
that there was some amount of error in
fraud so so Trump's just like look I
know that there were people that were
suppressing votes and people trying to
blah blah but I know that my voters came
out for me so go find those votes
because they're out there it wasn't like
he was like oh ghost stuff ballots into
a box not that I not that he wouldn't
put wouldn't do that if he could get
away with it because he would but I
don't think that he was I don't think
that he had any kind of plan to stuff
ballots or whatever at one point didn't
he make like an offhanded comment about
like voting twice or something I
remember when the left freaked out about
it it was a joke but I think uh I think
Roseanne may have been right
military tribunals by the end of the
year oh not that one rosenzo is not
going to be an election and Michael
malice said of course there will be and
then you know my response is of course
like Define we need to clarify what you
mean and I tweeted this earlier perhaps
she's right not in the literal sense
that all of a sudden there's no election
but if Donald Trump is removed from the
ballot in a single state can you really
call it a true election and that I think
is an interesting point
everyone knows the Front Runners Donald
Trump he's going to be the Nomine he's
going to be the nominee for the GOP Joe
Biden likely unless something changes it
could change but right now it's looking
like Biden versus Trump that's what the
polls are showing a lot can change from
now and then
if there is an election and Trump is
forcefully removed from the election
it's an election because the people
aren't given the choice they actually
want I agree you can you will people
will call it an election but if it isn't
actually an election and you doesn't
matter what you call it banana republics
they call them elections but you're like
you can't you can't legally cause
America you can't legally call American
cheese cheese that's why the package
says American pasteurized processed
cheese product we call it cheese we ask
for extra cheese when we put on our
Burgers but it is legally distinct from
cheese so that's the technicality I'm
referring to it is legally distinct from
Jesus it in fact is I love that I like
the comparison what I really love is I'm
a big fan of home run and pizza you guys
ever have home running I don't think uh
Chicago famous Chicago Pizza brand
they're amazing it's really good pizza
it's like a flat pizza and um you get
these little personal ones and it says
cheese pizza with pepperoni why because
they don't have the legal amount of
pepperoni on them to be called pepperoni
that's funny right so here's where
there's there's a legal amount
I think federally but here's my point my
point is that federal government at work
the left the Liberals will remove Trump
and then say we had a free and fair
election and the right will say our guy
was removed from the ballot how is that
a fair election and the left will just
say it let me let me read you this part
of this this is crazy check it out the
co-conspirators one an attorney who was
willing to spread lies they say false
claims too an attorney who devies an
attempt to implement a strategy three an
attorney whose undefined claims of
election fraud defendant privately
acknowledged others sounded crazy four a
doj official five an attorney so there's
what is this four attorneys advising
Donald Trump and they're like that makes
it a conspiracy so then you've got we're
doing the jobs co-conspirator sex a
political consultant who helped
Implement a plan to submit fraudulent
slights of presidential electors what
they're doing is they're saying it's
false because the media said so and the
electors are fraudulent because they
weren't elected despite the fact
Democrats had done this in 1960 they
sent a slate of elect actors they
convened and did everything despite the
fact the state was awarded to the
Republicans they did it anyway and then
when it came down to the actual
electoral vote Nixon the VP at the time
counted the Democrat votes instead so
when Donald Trump did exactly the same
thing now it's fraud this is a clear
sham an attempt this is the this is the
real conspiracy this is the real fraud
happening right in front of us Donald
Trump believed stupid things don't get
me wrong Donald Trump sought to legally
remedy these things when he's on the
phone with these people he genuinely
believes that lawyers telling him these
things are happening and he's like okay
and as Phil pointed out there is not an
ounce there is not a tiny there's not a
single cell in Trump's body that
believes he did not win every part of
him believes he won how could he lose
he's the biggest he's the best he's got
golden toilets and his lawyers told him
he did so he said pursue it they're
going after him claiming it yeah you met
like not only is the guy like really
really strongly uh prone to think that
he won because of his ego then he's got
lawyers that are like yeah dude you're
totally right he's like he's not
he's not gonna be able to know everyone
else is right I I'm PR me and me and the
guys that are literally telling me
exactly what I want to hear we we're
probably well and it's like they're jobs
too and yeah they're listed as
co-conspirators for doing their jobs
being attorneys it's just the craziest
thing they're indicting his attorneys
for legally advising him yeah I would
imagine that if the attorneys believed
what they were saying then they're not
committing crimes well in attorneys I
don't think have to believe what they're
saying I mean it's their job to defend
their client yeah that's the entire
point of it I don't even think you
legally have to believe you know you're
claiming murder cases you know a lot of
I mean this is obviously different but
attorneys represent murderers all the
time look at O.J Simpson you know he did
it but you know
there are times where you'll have a
murder case where it's like you're
getting charged with one like murder one
and the the attorney will just swear up
and down that it was just manslaughter
right like they knew that that you
killed him but it wasn't intended you
know so details like that matter and
there going to say whatever they need to
say to get their client off you know
yeah so if it turns out that Trump
believed what he was saying I mean first
of all how in the hell can you prove
that in court you can't you cannot it
only he knows that's why I didn't go
after perjury because it's impossible
most cases to prove someone was lying so
if it turns out he wasn't lying he was
just wrong then does that not just clear
all these other people then because
there was no conspiracy because there
was no credit you would think it would
clear this entire indictment because the
entire indictment is a you know based on
him allegedly knowing beforehand and
then lying about it so that this
indictment I mean it's just BS that's
the best well so here's my question
How can there be an election in 2024
with this already coming down
because what we see here is I'll say it
again in 1960 Republicans win Hawaii
Democrats convene electors anyway fill
out the requisite forms and send them to
DC even though they lost
in the end Nixon decides to count the
Democrat electoral votes anyway because
there's a court hearing they were not
certified he says we're going to count
these ones as anybody object okay there
they go to Kennedy instead Trump's team
does that they're claiming that's a
conspiracy the the doj Biden Biden's doj
is claiming that Trump knew he was lying
that his attorneys were conspiring with
him to willfully lie and defraud the
country to steal an election
with them saying this and of course not
a single Trump supporter believes this
is true How can there be an election in
2024. let's say that
Donald Trump doesn't get criminal he
doesn't get convicted he's on the ballot
we make it to November and then they say
go cast your votes
how could anyone on the left believe it
if Trump wins how could anyone on the
right believe it if Biden wins yeah
that's where I have that too man like
with with people voting on a proprietary
voting machine behind the scenes and
then them just spitting you out and them
telling us what our votes said without
verification how I am lost I'm like I
I'm so far out of the political realm I
see no no solution within that broken
within that I guess you would call
obfuscated system I I can't I can't I
don't know what what strings to pull on
because I don't know where what they're
connected to because I can't see the
code what happens what happens in 2024
the day after the election and they say
the winner of the 2024 race is insert
Canada
for this country yeah how are you going
to prove it that you know that candidate
didn't win or did win you can't because
like Eaton said who's counting our votes
we're not but but I'm not even talking
about that it doesn't matter who wins
what happens to this country when one or
the other wins that's gonna fall apart
regardless I think I mean we saw the
reaction to when Trump won you see the
2020 riots you see everything that
happened and then you see the reaction
to when Biden wins you know either side
is going to be very uncomfortable
regardless of who wins it's just a
matter of you know which side is going
to be more uncomfortable and obviously
the left is always going to be the more
uncomfortable side when the opposing
candidate wins but I think they're right
it's kind of scary because in this
situation it's like they're trying to
push the right into the extremism box
that they've already labeled them in
that's their goal I feel like here they
want these you know right-wing
terrorists and right-wing extremists to
go out and act like antifa I mean look
at what they did with j6 right that that
is their goal I think here because
because then they can say look you know
these people are insane they're
everything we've been telling you they
are for the past 10 years
and it's just another I feel like it's
just going to be another step towards
the ultimate dehumanization process that
we're seeing in the country yeah when if
for instance Biden wins in 24 and then
people are just out of their minds
frustrated with the system whether Trump
got elected was in the election or not
they're going to look for like moral
Solace of some sort to not go crazy and
it's really our job or the job of you
listening you like all of us to keep
people saying keep your friends and
neighbors sane because if they do snap
they'll be used as an example just like
your sand Taylor and just what you
Hitler did when the reichstag burned
down he blamed the Communists and he
sent the whole country to martial law so
do not step on that landmine
if Trump wins the left will say oh no
the fascists are taking over he's a
criminal and he's been indicted and we
all know it he's trying to defraud this
country there's no way this is
legitimate Vladimir Putin's probably
helping him
then what if Joe Biden wins then the
right is going to say
it's clearly the Deep State it's clearly
fraud
what happens I can't I can't predict I
have no idea well did you see uh the
other day this I don't remember you know
who it was It was obviously a left wing
he's a fairly famous character he was on
Joe Rogan's podcast and Rogan was
pushing him uh you know on the question
of you know are the bidens corrupt like
you're supposed oh yeah Jim Gaffigan
yeah and uh you know he just it was
clearly he didn't believe in anything
that he was saying he was just
stuttering and mumbling he was trying
to do but I think I think it just shows
you that like it doesn't matter what
really happens the left is gonna be
unhappy regardless and they're just
going to continue to get more unhappy
these aren't happy people and they can
never really achieve happiness or
Solitude in their political candidates I
mean they're unhappy with Biden still so
I think you're just going to keep seeing
both sides being pushed and pushed and
pushed and pushed until there's finally
a Breaking Point again like 2021 I think
2024 is going to be a Breaking Point oh
I think it is going to be too that's
what Roseanne was saying she was saying
something the fact there won't be an
election and the idea that there is no
election is absurd but it will be an
election as people will go vote there
will be ballots but will anyone believe
the results it's a full election yeah no
I mean like it might be a I might be
real might be legitimate but no one will
not be able to know that's the problem
we don't see the code tallying the votes
for us how can we know but that doesn't
even matter because it's not all digital
some is paper or some some of some of
these places do take paper ballots the
point is it doesn't matter if if the
vote is two people and you and I walk in
the room and I hold up a sign saying
Trump and yield up a sign saying Trump
and we go there it is Trump won the left
won't care they'll say it doesn't matter
that he won fascists have taken over and
now you must resist yeah I think you're
right about that whoever seizes the
power at the top it doesn't really
matter to the crowd to the to the people
to the culture and that's why I'm so
heavily focused on creating songs and
and movies right now I don't it doesn't
seem like it's a direct line to
Salvation like make a hit movie but I
mean it can't hurt it can only do good
and I know that during World War II
artists thrived you know in deep dark
times is when people really really need
someone to make them laugh or to make
them smile or to give them hope so maybe
maybe that'll well you see that all
throughout history is that's when
artists Thrive is the darkest times
throughout history and not just that but
musicians people that give somebody hope
even if it's you know through a dark
message they're always going to thrive
because people are always looking for
something to latch onto because in a
society what are you going to latch on
to now what child drag shows like what
moral things are in America right now
and as it declines even more for you to
latch onto and to be proud of there's
pretty much nothing yeah we need
structural reorganization in the United
States big time man I don't know if the
three branches of government's enough if
we need a fourth branch of government
like the national initiative Mike Revell
was working on the national initiative
before he passed away that's an
interesting concept that microville is a
communist I don't think so that guy was
lit his it's the young guys he let take
over people running his Twitter account
have kind of trash dragged it through
the mud no offense guys I don't know if
you actually have but I have not been
it's not Mike Revel let's put it down
Communists I'm comfortable with the
offense
um so if we need if we need a fourth
branch of government so that people have
more of a voice in writing and creating
laws and passing them into the Senate
because right now it's like a monopoly
of like 300 400 people they get to get
to do that but can you I don't know I
was gonna say can you really trust the
government to give people more power
because whenever you know they've
they've tried to give people more power
it ends up with them we are the
government laws inherently do not
Empower people but like every law that
the government passes or that gets
passed takes power away from the
individual and from the people so you
would be able to repeal laws also give
the national initiative I'm not sure if
that's written in but let's do it give
people the opportunity but also who's in
charge of repealing the laws and stating
new laws that's where you run into the
problem in the roadblock because not
everybody's going to agree with it and
why would the government want why would
the government allow a new Branch the
existing government the the probably the
Congress or and the the executive why
would the government allow a new Branch
to repeal laws when Congress is fully
empowered to do that now it would be
still the Senate and laws don't matter
at all anyway yeah fair enough
enforcement is what matters so either we
you know if we want there to truly be
changes in this country it has to be
cultural meaning the people genuinely
agree that something is Over The Line
and other things are not and that's
where a lot of the cultural culture War
stuff is is taking place in areas where
the right and the left fundamentally
disagree on what is okay and what isn't
okay like for instance many liberals are
okay with books like genderqueer and
this book is gay which contains sexually
graphic images they're okay with those
books being given to minor children for
whatever reason and then people on the
right are not okay with that the law is
clear you can't allow this but police
will not enforce it period yeah that's a
cultural issue I've only ever seen the
police like referring to child drag
shows which is clear I mean sexual
manipulate I mean you're taking
advantage of these kids in an
intentional way in corrupting their
minds and you know I've covered over
probably 50 of these just in Texas alone
there's only been one single one where
anything was enforced and it wasn't
against the drag performers it was
against antifa so they're not unwilling
to enforce it even though though it's
clearly stated that it's against the law
and then we have sb12 passed which in
September is going to go into state that
it actually is against the law the
revoke business licenses there'll be
jail time amongst other things but it's
still going to happen and none of it's
going to be enforced we need to show
people like when I pick up that book
genderqueer and I turn to the page where
the the young kid has like a strap on
and the other kids like getting down to
go go down on this other you're like if
I sh maybe someone needs to see me
showing a 14 year old that to see how
horrific it is but even go to jail
exactly but it's how can that okay just
put it behind a curtain and say it's
fine like you cannot let that happen
sorry Taylor yeah I mean but the left
does allow it yeah it's because they are
communists they're protected I think
it's because a lot of people don't know
what's happening so they're just going
along with it like Emma viglin was on
the culture where she's like oh yeah
that book's great didn't even know what
she was talking about she didn't know
had never obviously never read the book
but but that's that that matters to a
certain degree but the real issue is
there's a there's a video of a guy
backing away from anti-funt in Seattle
they're threatening him with weapons and
the cops pull up jump out and arrest the
victim if you tried saying everyone look
at this book look what they're doing to
kids they'll be like oh well you just
committed a crime in courtrooms they're
like don't it's too graphic don't show
us we can't know and you're like dude
you gotta know man don't if the teacher
nothing will happen
if you are an opponent of the Communists
and you show it you will be arrested
well look it's a perfect example with
with this topic I mean you look at the
2020 riots right and then the one time
the right decides to write look at the
prosecution difference I mean when the
dissenters do something that they're not
supposed to you know while the other
side's completely allowed to it's just
as illegal they they're paid antifa
millions of dollars when they ride and D
write it in DC during Trump's
inauguration they smashed buildings that
cost millions of dollars in damage they
caused they destroyed private vehicles
at fires in the streets torched a
limousine and then when the police
arrested him the cops got in trouble and
the city paid out millions of dollars to
antifa as the victims and then a couple
years later the vice president was
hockey or plugging their uh defense fund
well you look at the Portland defense
fund with Rose City antifa and those
groups when I went to jail with them in
2020 I mean I was talking to him they
have millions of dollars in that defense
fund when I last talked to him it was
like 3.8 million dollars and all that
money is recycled because they're not
getting prosecuted they show up to their
trial they don't get prosecuted that
money goes right back in and they just
keeps stacking and stacking and stacking
but you don't see anything like that on
the right who has control of that fund I
don't know somebody somebody has control
so how do we get blue how do we fix this
stuff man how do we get in there and
make this like us I think it all comes
down to culture I think that's the most
understated and you know I mean I would
say underestimated aspect and Tim has
done really I mean this whole crew has
done really good on hitting on the
culture more so than anybody on the
right is we should be making movies like
daily wire we should be making songs
like Tim you have to affect the culture
to change it I mean you got to change
people's minds and that is through
culture Let's uh let's jump to the store
we got this one from CW Atlanta security
barricades placed around Fulton County
Courthouse in Atlanta they are slow
rolling this one and we know what's
about to happen Fulton County D.A says
her team's work is accomplished setting
stage for Trump indictment announcement
as many as 18 people could be charged in
connection with attempts to overturn the
2020 election results I am mad at the
Democrats I'm not mad
at Republicans yep the Republicans in
all of these different states and all
these different places do nothing they
don't use their power even when we do
have even when the right does have power
they don't use it they refuse to use it
because they don't want to be seen as
you know these right-wing fascist
dictators but the left they don't I
don't believe I don't know I believe
that I think that the Republicans who
are claiming they don't want to be
tyrannical are actually just in on it oh
yeah well it's a uniparty through and
through you know you have a select few
people you know congressmen
Representatives that maybe not be a part
of it they were not at the same time
yeah there's always going to be conflict
and the UNA party is still strong and
it's going to stay strong it's just a
matter of breaking that up how do you do
that where are we at with impeaching Joe
Biden over his obvious and discernible
Shady business dealings with his son
where where are we at there uh it Kevin
McCarthy said we are now going to begin
the process of beginning an inquiry into
impeachment yep
so it'll never happen so now now we're
at the point where we decided to start
the process of asking the question does
this rise to the level of impeachment
which we already know it clearly does
but it's just a pony show that's really
it all it is is it's just four show it's
to give people false hope you understand
they're fighting back oh yeah I mean he
could have been I think he could have
been impeached within his first month in
office I mean with all the evidence even
there was enough evidence with Hunter
Biden yeah if you want to make an
argument that those were pre-bidden
presidency then okay then Afghanistan
outright I mean that was such a disaster
and utter failure it warrants removal in
my opinion all the stuff that's coming
out about barisma and Ukraine and stuff
the the that's plenty of reason to
impeach there's that there's sufficient
evidence yeah just the uh the testimony
from uh what's his name last night or
whatever the the guest on the show last
night no no the uh The Whistleblower
yeah The Whistleblower um I mean Joe
Biden was listening to all the
conversations Joe Biden would call all
of Hunter Biden's uh
just to be like hey I'm Joe Biden he's
actually like he can actually get me to
to you know help out if he needs if he
needs help so you should probably do
what he says that's exactly what it was
it was it's as it's clear corruption and
I I don't know like I said like I said
last night I don't have a whole lot of
Hope in any kind of
you know impeachment or any kind of
actual Republicans don't do anything
yeah even at the state level what we're
looking at with the Fulton County D.A
this is this is local politics going
after Trump trying to stop him from
being able to run they don't want an
election the Democrats are doing this
because they know they lose
they will lose in if if everything is
done standard fair I wonder if they
would like lose like in a landslide
because like this the majority of people
are like really over the but once you
once you touch people's money it's over
once you touch people's money I think
that's the biggest indicator I have
left-wing people that I talk to all the
time that are suffering financially
that's the biggest hit I think that you
can do on somebody is once you mess with
somebody's Pockets they're going to
notice
I mean yeah
I mean there's there's sufficient reason
for the for the American people to not
like Joe Biden there is ample reason I
don't think that that he's a popular
president I don't think you need to
convince people that Joe Biden has done
you know a bad job I I don't think
that's the argument that the I think uh
that anyone really needs to make I think
people need to read you know more
history if you look at countries that
fall into Revolution or Civil War
because what's happening now with the
indictment of Donald Trump the third
technically what about the third
indictment
potentially moving to the fourth this is
worse than what happened in some of the
you know greater Revolutions in Civil
Wars throughout history up to a certain
point obviously so you know I was
reading about the uh the Revolutions in
Russia star Nicholas and things like
that Spanish Civil War Weimar Germany
and there were things that happened that
were considered to be major catalysts of
Revolution Civil War that were not on
par with one leader weaponizing
government against his rival political
faction to this degree some of these
major political moments were like a
referendum was held and power was
transferred from the executive branch to
the you know to Parliament and it's like
that was considered a great Revolution
and things like that it was like a
tremendous moment happened when the
monarchy transferred certain executive
powers to parlor for parliamentary
decisions and they call that the great
upheaval or something like that this is
Joe Biden is trying to physically remove
his his principal rival because he's
losing in the polls
well I don't know about because he's
losing in the polls I think he would do
that even if he was winning the polls
well what I mean is like yeah we can we
can we can look at the polls and see
Biden's losing yeah and it would seem
that the only reason to really go for
Trump in this way is because they know
they can't win like like I said earlier
today I I think that that this is bigger
than Trump I think that this is about
making a statement about people that are
Outsiders not even really attempting to
get into the the office and and and kind
of bust your way into the Inner Circle
and try to make changes and make demands
I really think that the the the
established bureaucracy really hates
Trump because he would have made
significant changes if he if they
allowed him to we got to stay him I want
to read Trump's statement he is he
responded to the indictment he says this
is nothing more than the latest corrupt
chapter in the continued pathetic
attempt by the Biden crime family and
their weaponized Department of Justice
to interfere in the 2024 presidential
election in which president Trump is the
Undisputed FrontRunner and leading by
substantial margin but why did they wait
two and a half years to bring these fake
charges right in the middle of President
Trump's winning campaign for 2024.
why was it was it announced the day
after the big crooked Joe Biden scandal
broke out from the halls of Congress the
answer is election interference the
lawlessness of these persecutions of
President Trump and his supporters is
reminiscent of Nazi Germany in the 1930s
the former Soviet Union and the
authoritarian dictatorial regimes and
other authoritarian dictatorial regimes
president Trump has always filed the law
on the Constitution with advice for many
highly accomplished attorneys these
Un-American witch hunts will fail and
president Trump will be re-elected to
the White House so we can save our
country from the abuse and competence
and Corruption that is running through
the veins of our country at levels never
seen before three years ago we had
strong borders energy Independence no
inflation and a great economy today we
are a nation in Decline president Trump
will not be deterred by disgraceful and
unprecedented political targeting
well I don't think I think we were still
in Decline we were just in a bubble uh
the Federal Reserve screwed us 2007 was
on the obvious example of how we're in
Decline we've been in Decline since we
went on fiat currency so I can't stand
when Trump takes credit for a booming
economy when it was a bubble but that
part other than that part he's this
sounds about right you do not per
politically persecute your opponents in
the middle of an election season the day
after your son gets shown for being
corrupt I mean this is what they claimed
Trump was doing they claimed Trump was
trying to dig up dirt on Joe Biden and
that was impeachable offense Joe Biden
is literally indicting the front runner
and they're like it's a good thing these
are evil people they know what they're
doing they know they are evil yeah I
agree with those typical blame others of
what you're guilty of that's really what
we're seeing here and they're just going
to continue to do so and they're and the
Republicans do nothing they're guarding
that inner circle of the unit party like
Hillary's still pissed that Trump said
you'd be in jail on the state humiliated
her like she's not gonna let that go
she's going to watch till her last day
on Earth she's going to be wanting to
make that guy's life miserable and she's
a lot of connections and a lot of power
in the US government obviously
um
and that's I that that's why I get to
the point where I'm like nothing I can
do can help this system nothing I can do
politically can help if I I don't even
want Trump to get elected but if I want
to do nothing I can do could help him
get elected nothing all I can do is make
hit records and maybe people will cry in
their sleep and realize that life's not
so bad and I mean each other helping
someone get elected is quite simple if
you go to someone and say register to
vote and vote for Trump you are helping
Trump get elected
the reason I said no I feel like nothing
I can do is because I feel like if I got
100 million of a million people
registered it would just it doesn't
matter because I don't I can't read the
vote you got to prove to me that that
voting system is legit if you're gonna
do that in secret then I don't have any
evidence that you're doing it right it's
like secret Bell is always been the
thing in the U.S like well we don't we
don't get to see
who voted for who yeah but the idea that
we take all the ballots send them to a
private company that goes behind a black
curtain and comes out and says trust us
this guy won yep yeah BS
that that that's we can't we can't work
that way and so now we're seeing there's
been there's been like Court rulings
overturning these these attempts to stop
Universal mail and voting and things
like this
if it if it comes down to ease of access
for random people to vote Democrats are
for it if it comes down to security
Republicans are for it
I'm not I'm neither I just want like
secure I mean secure the right way sorry
to interrupt you what were you about to
say I I just want transparency in my
election process so that's security yeah
that's what's the right response and
that's what this whole thing has been
about is we want fair and free elections
we want transparent elections you have
to but then I could see like the if the
mob truly voted in a psychopath you want
like someone behind this curtain being
like uh Psychopaths can't get in or
we'll lose everything okay let's no well
I mean if you look at like if you're
actually talking about a psychopath
right like majority of CEOs or
Psychopaths I'd say a good majority of
our presidents have been Psychopaths
because you need that extra Edge I mean
I I say God you know gifted a
Psychopaths for a reason granted not a
lot of them are great but we need them
in society they're a natural occurring
let me let me read this tweet from uh
Jack the sobeck he said the Trump case
has been assigned to U.S District Judge
Tanya s chutcon according to the court
docket chitcon and Obama appointee is
the only federal judge in D.C who has
sentenced j6 defendants to sentence
sentence is longer than the government
had requested
very obvious where this is going yep
y'all are in a civil war and people like
to ignore it but just read about the U.S
Civil War the Spanish Civil War the the
the Russian revolutions there was more
than one read about the French
Revolution more than one
and it's interesting how they kind of
like 75 years to figure out how to like
have a proper government that's in
foreign
first they had a revolution and then
Napoleon became emperor yeah it's like
huh and another Revolution they had a
revolution that went wrong and then
wrote they start killing people that was
the big problem that was back before
Napoleon and then after robe sphere was
killed there was some turmoil then
Napoleon was worried about Russia he was
like I'll take it and the Bolsheviks
right about Russia is particularly
interesting failed leadership people
were unhappy is a simple way to put it
and so you take a look at what's going
on now and this reaches the level of
historical
historical Revolution Civil War or
collection and it makes sense on the
timeline of History because all the
cultures of Earth are blending now and
causing mass chaos in the United States
particularly is like the is the front
runner so it makes sense that we'd be
facing revolutionary pressure or or
civil unrest or Civil War like pressure
it makes total sense now we just got to
see how do we fortify against it because
if it's obvious that it's happening it
makes sense that it would be happening
then there's got to be an antidote but
how do you fortify against something
when you don't control the institutions
we don't control any sort of power
whatsoever regarding the institutions
and the institutions are going to be
where the majority of the ideological uh
basically brainwashing is carried out I
guess you build your own institutions
it's challenging when you're up against
a monopoly um like mines is like a
social network that's free software uh
has no political leanings
um you know daily wire is a good example
of something that appeared out of uh or
like uh Angel Studios you know that's
kind of a new institution that can make
whatever movie that want and it'll get
put in movie theaters around the world
regardless of the gatekeeps
that's one way to do it well let's talk
about this well they are accusing Donald
Trump of instigating January 6. we have
new evidence as to who actually was
behind January 6 and it was ladies and
gentlemen Joe Rogan that's right Ray
Epps's attorney responds to allegations
of Klein's involvement January 6th he
said the absurdity of the conspiracy
theory does not stand in the way of it
being spread and weaponized uh to harm
right if Mr Rogan is truly interested in
focusing on who instigated the attack on
the capital he would find more truth
looking at the mirror than he does in
focusing on a wedding venue owner from
Arizona so basically my eyes must have
lied to me on January 6th when I
witnessed Ray Epps whispered Orion
Sampson and the barriers went down it
must have actually been Joe Rogan doing
the whisper in that day Ray apps is on
camera yelling at people to go into the
capital oh he's on camera and then he's
on the front holding the Trump thing as
the bearings are torn down well I don't
know he was ramming cops he was holding
a barrier that eventually ended up
ramming cops a huge Trump sign that they
picked up sideways into officers but
that means I can tell you that the dude
told people to go in the building and
that is on the front line when they
breached the capitol grounds that's
enough well and then I remember seeing
him multiple times throughout the day on
the initial breach you know in the
secondary breach I mean right as
everything really hit the fan that's
when he backed off he just backed off
and kind of faded away into the crowd
and just watched it all take place so I
don't know a clear investigation proves
that he's a Fed a lot of people think he
is but I do think it's absolutely
fascinating that the lawyer is trying to
say that Joe Rogan in any way instigated
January 6 when Rogan's never even had
Trump on his podcast and he refuses to
have Trump on his podcast from what I'm
aware of I don't know I don't know I
don't know if that's I think that's the
media exaggerating I think it's more
like Joe doesn't probably doesn't care
all that much
I mean he already has what the largest
podcast in the entire isn't it either so
he wanted to have him on early early on
2019 or something and then I heard that
he doesn't he's kind of given up he's
like I'm not I'm not getting involved
with that I don't know it feels like
after the Spotify deal it's a different
show yeah absolutely free Spotify it was
like the craziest Alex Jones ever and
now post Spotify it's people he finds
interesting and wants to hang out with
and just talk to it seems like he he was
able to like with the guaranteed Revenue
stream just make the show about the
conversations he wants to have
but I digress this is the narrative that
they that they push right in the
indictment against Donald Trump they say
he was spreading false narratives what
they're really saying is he spread a
narrative that defied the corporate
press
what they're saying here now is Joe
Rogan speaks a narrative that defies the
corporate press therefore you are the
enemy you are their enemy and you are
the one causing all the problems
the solution of course I think is
cultural anyone that pushes back gets
thrown into the basket of deplorables
anyone that doesn't totally accept the
official narrative you're cast into the
into the the Trump supporting racist
bigot you know misogynist sexist but you
know the whole thing works it works but
at the same time I think it's gonna
reach a point because it's happening so
much more consistently with people that
are clearly not Trump supporters aren't
you know right-wing fascists or what
they're being labeled that you're
throwing so many people that don't
qualify into this basket that eventually
the basket is going to be too full and
you're going to be outnumbered because
they're turning on their own I mean in a
lot of these cases also if enough people
speak out against the corporate media at
the same time their people don't get
grabbed it's only when like they'll go
after and it's easy to go after
individuals after a couple weeks go by
you're like all right that one guy made
too much noise about it on Tuesday but
like if if everyone's or enough people
are just launching about the obvious
fraudulence or or mistakes and things
it's this is what I'm saying about
culture if the culture is you get a
million views on Tick Tock and YouTube
when you insult Joe Biden Joe Biden
loses the election
that's the culture needs to be built
that's why they employ these like young
gen Z influencers well they also allow
the left-wing influencers on and then
immediately remove the right wing
influencers from what I've seen I mean I
had a tick tock it was like 260 000
followers it's strikes
band yeah it's not but it may have
launched a new one though it's not just
the political people like Ronnie Radke
just got his Tick Tock uh Ronnie Radke
is the singer of being called uh Falling
in Reverse
um and they're great massive massive he
got he got banned he just got his Tick
Tock band because he was making talking
about trans people and I'm not sure
exactly what he said I didn't I don't
have the uh the stuff in front of me
transcript
well I mean I don't he was he was
talking about trans people
um I don't know what like I said I don't
know what he said but and they they
banned him and like I said this guy I
mean he is fairly like controversial in
the in the rock and heavy metal World in
that he's he's he you know he's a rock
rock star you know I mean he I think he
threw a mic stand into the crowd one
time and he gets into beef with people
on Twitter and and you know he doesn't
do what he's quote unquote supposed to
do but they you know they they booted
him off of uh off of tick tock and and
that's he's not a political guy he just
said something that was Politically
Incorrect sounds a lot like the guy
sitting right next to me I'm well I mean
I've said some things a rock singer
that's Ronnie Radke's description on uh
falling in reverse.com yeah I'm waiting
to Google your name and and see uh you
know the right wing label slapped on
your Wikipedia oh well I don't know
about my Wikipedia But if you go to any
of the metal blogs most of them yeah
I've seen I've seen those articles yeah
they don't like me and I don't care
because they're scum I've never had a
tick tock anecdotally I don't I don't
hate people involved in the Chinese
Communist party it's a little concerning
to have a uniparty dictating Central
planning of a system
um I don't hate those people I will
never use I should maybe Never Never Say
Never but I have no interest in using
that uh manipulative trash Tick Tock but
you look at you look at the massive
reach though Tick Tock the amount of
views they bring in it blows other
platforms and anybody can go viral
that's that's the nice thing about Tick
Tock but the right needs to use that
that's a sad reality of it you need the
ride on Tick Tock you need their ideas
because that's where young kids I mean
that's that's what they do all day they
just sit up and swipe it doesn't say a
on your Wikipedia page that you're right
wing but it does smear you pretty bad it
says that you're a fan of Taylor Swift
uh you know
sometimes sometimes the internet uh gets
something right you know yeah it just
says that you're you're a recurring
guest on this show and you're a
Libertarian or something that's cool
moved to New Hampshire to join the
libertarian movement so when you said
everyone's got to use the or you got to
use tick tock to get through to the
people I feel like that's like saying
here if we were in a war or something
you're like here use the enemy's weapons
that are tracking you every move because
they're better weapons yeah but you're
going to be tracked regardless look at
Instagram look at Twitter I mean all
these are data harvesting companies
you're tracked no matter what you have
an electronic device in your pocket at
all times you know the tick tock isn't
going to track you any better than all
these other apps that are harvesting
it's the CCP I don't want the CCP to be
tracking me yeah I think I need the
least of your worries though were the
CCP right like your own government has
been weaponized against you right now
they're the ones you should be worried
about of course CCP is a threat I don't
know I mean don't much more threatening
the Chinese communist part is much more
threatening to the American civilians I
agree and you don't want to be on Tick
Tock because this idea that you join
Tick Tock for the purpose of engaging in
that conflict perhaps makes sense to a
certain degree but we want to force the
conversation onto the platforms where we
have more control yeah I can agree with
that but at the same time Tick Tock you
can transfer those you know your
audience off of that to the necessary
actually really that's why they ban you
yeah well Tick Tock that was my hardest
thing is you know I had 260 000
followers but it was the actual return
rate to your other platforms but if you
gather enough followers you get enough
engagement you do get a little bit of
return rate there but you also want to
make sure you're on pla on these
platform so you can push back to the
extent you're able to push back well
there's upsides and downsides of course
to it all but I I think in the end you
know it would be beneficial for the
right at least to have some sort of
presence on the app yeah the only
problem with having Tick Tock is like
having it on your phone that you use and
it's constantly trying to get into your
phone book and stuff like that like
that's the problem with otherwise like
the the access and the reach that you
can get there's no there's nothing bad
about that yeah to be honest with you I
wish that like uh Instagram and and
other social media uh sites would be a
little more forthcoming about how you
massage the algorithm and how you make
sure to get your stuff in because if you
go to tick tock and you go to the the
creators page or whatever they give you
it tells you how they give you a list
right down the list and you can you can
hit all the bullet points and you will
go from having no one to having tons and
tons of followers Tick Tock is the only
platform where you can gain hundreds of
thousands of followers in less than 24
hours that's insane so many people I
can't I don't know if it's real or not I
don't think it is sorry for over here I
don't think I don't think yeah I would
not be surprised if they're shoving AI
followers down your throat to make
Americans think they're getting
something out of it we've talked about
it before the way the way you start a
social media Network anyone can do this
right now
start start a social media Network
put out advertisements to uh you know
certain age younger age demographic 18
year olds when they sign up start giving
them followers rather quickly fake ones
and they feel like they're getting
social a dopamine hit right over and
over then when they post you give them
more likes then what happens is 18 year
old kid who's a freshman in college or
senior in high school goes to his
friends and goes I'm on labonte.com and
I've already got 10 000 followers and
they're like you have 10 000 followers
which you're on that stupid old school
YouTube I'm on labonte.com and then all
of a sudden these other kids are like I
want to get followers too and they all
start signing up all their followers are
fake but this attracts everyone to the
platform exactly so I don't believe tick
tock's real at this point maybe to a
certain degree but I still think you
know I'll just put it this way I they
they in my opinion there's a strong
likelihood that they did something that
effect oh absolutely I mean I got it I
remember one of my first videos ever was
like a million likes it wasn't it wasn't
it two different apps before it was
called like musically and like Lively or
something yeah yeah well and it used to
be a dancing app musically it was like a
lip syncing dancing app yeah and they
merged two apps and turn it into Tick
Tock did you get paid on Tick Tock you
can for Creator funds but only if you
tow the lines and you're making dancing
tick tocks you know as a political
commentator you're not getting paid from
taking so your your first video went
viral my first very video it was when I
was painting murals when I was doing
activism before journalism got over a
million likes how soon how fast that was
within four days it was insane and I
went over from I mean I think I had a
hundred thousand plus followers after
just one video and then every single
video I posted after that well over I
mean a million views it was you know
there was good engagement but you don't
know if that's real or fake or not at
the same time so there were two apps
Tick Tock did launch and there was also
musically they bought musically and then
merged it in and then got rid of
musically musically was the lip syncing
app I knew people who had accounts and
they were telling me how I got to get on
the platform because it was way better
and they have hundreds of thousands of
followers or one person was like I have
a million followers and I was like let
me pull up the app and I pulled it up
and it was like all the comments were
just like sweet rad nice the most
automated responses ever and I was like
I don't think you're actually you don't
have that many at all but you know the
thing is
they don't care all they want to do is
go to advertisers and be able to say
hey look they may be lying I'm not going
to say it I'm not going to accuse anyone
committing of committing a crime then
these these creators and influencers can
go to ad agencies and say I get a
billion views per month yep and they'll
be like wow what do you want and that's
it and you get money that could be a
scandal that's uncovered later where
we're like wow like yeah I'll tell you
about a meeting I had uh with Discovery
in uh Discovery Channel in San Francisco
where we sat down and this is probably
10 years ago this is probably eight
years ago
and they said what do you think about
Facebook yes it's probably about nine
eight or nine years ago what do you
think about Facebook videos versus
YouTube and I said YouTube is clearly
where it's at in terms of cultural
influence this is a decade ago by mind
what mind you and then one guy is one
guy goes yeah but on Facebook we're
getting 10 times the views
and I'm like
are you really getting the views
rolling past the video and it's adding
to the count whereas YouTube is someone
actually watches the video and it shows
you the average watch time in a much
more detail in this lunch it was more
than just Discovery I can't remember who
said it it's been like a decade but
someone said something like
you know what ultimately doesn't matter
because these are the numbers we deliver
to advertisers yep and so they were like
let's just go to the advertisers and say
we got a hundred million views and I
think there's a lawsuit over this
because uh advertisers were advertisers
were buying view on Facebook views on
Facebook for these videos they were
buying Impressions and they weren't
getting delivered anything legitimate
I want like on YouTube all my
subscribers I want a button that will
let me clear anyone that subscribed me
that hasn't logged into YouTube in the
last year I want them removed I don't
want those numbers I want real numbers
even if it's less yo Ronnie said that
men can't have a period and that's why
he lost his Tick Tock wow
honestly worth it worth it yeah because
he's totally telling the truth when I
got into mines we started building free
software I became a bit of a zealot like
I'm just going to stop using the
proprietary crap I'm gonna stop using
YouTube stop using Twitter stop using
Facebook and Bill the CEO of Mines
convinced me like just keep using that
stuff it's it feels dirty but like it's
market research so maybe there's an
argument to use tick tock I just feel
like I'll get banned within you know a
month oh you will talk about free speech
Let's jump to this story from timgas.com
new 2024 polls show Biden alternating
alternately tying with and sliding
behind Trump despite the possibility of
four separate sets of indictments
support for Trump remains strong
this is bad news they say a key strategy
for Biden's election bid will be
branding trumpism and Maga threat to
America casting Trump supporters as far
at authoritarians as access described
and let me also add personally one
tactic of Joe Biden is to criminally
indict his his opponent because clearly
you can't win legitimately interactive
polls show that Donald Trump is beating
Biden by three points among moderate
independencies of nine in swing States
Trump is up nine this is bad news for
Joe Biden and may explain why they're so
desperately going after Trump with these
indictments because Trump's going to win
and you know we had people we had you
know Liam last night he was convinced
Trump could not win because the Deep
state would not allow it to happen and
I'm just like they allowed it in 2016
then it's like is that is that the
argument in 2016 the Deep State went
like oops Trump won maybe I think so
because the way he was saying and what I
agree with is that now that he said when
I get back in all of you in the Deep
state are going to be fired they're like
okay this isn't the Trump from 2016. now
it's a different guy with a different
motive and I still don't think it means
they're powerful enough to stop him from
winning they can certainly throw
roadblocks in the way and try and go up
against him and criminal and charge him
right yeah but it does not mean look his
polls are gonna Skyrocket because of
this his fundraising is going to
Skyrocket because of this they cannot
stop him they're making they're playing
the game in desperation they're
thrashing about as they drown well the
reality of it is is all this propaganda
and the fake indictments wouldn't be
necessary if they didn't think he could
win they would just leave him alone
exactly and so what I see with this is
as we have tremendous victories with Bud
Light and things like this on cultural
fronts and sound to Freedom they are
going for the only thing they have left
which is raw government power they are
losing culturally their shows are
getting roasted
alter alternate Independent Media is
starting to rise Bud Light Lost a
quarter of its market share from
endorsing this stuff not popular nobody
likes it Trump is his popularity is
going up he's improving in the polls the
only thing they have left is
truncheons
do you think that if we replaced a lot
of the people in the government that it
would work better do you think it's a
problem is Personnel or is it structure
both eliminate
hold on you you replace a lot of people
it'll be better for sure you eliminate a
lot of positions and departments and
replace people we can fix the problem
yep
it's just like with the FBI you can't
just get new people you need to gut the
agency figure out what powers they have
what powers they don't so and then they
can't go out on a rampage like they have
been the past two years again but let's
uh let's add into the mix the other
question in this presidential debate
if Trump is indicted and removed will
Ron DeSantis be the nominee and uh
ultimately let's just uh let's just talk
a little bit about where Rhonda
Sanchez's campaign is at and my friends
the latest reporting that's come out
about Ron desantis's campaign is I'll
call it heartbreaking because I think
back to the promise we saw with a Rhonda
Sanders campaign somebody who was
pushing good culture War policy who was
uh pushing a lot of the same policies As
Trump but with more attacked Youth and
vigor and then Ron DeSantis
burned it all to the ground and I and I
do hold him personally responsible I
understand that it's his PR and
Communications team that are ultimately
syncing everything around him but the
fact that he has not fired Christina
Pasha at this point despite every insane
error she's made he's just like nah keep
doing your thing even though he's
collapsed in the polls he's basically no
longer even in the race well you saw the
the statement that like the internal
statement that was leaked of what was it
hit the brakes on what doesn't work hit
the gas on what does it's like then you
think you would hit the break on
Christina pushball because this is
clearly not working for this campaign
who said the historius was that DeSantis
himself it was it was a communications
director you know basically sending it
out to the influencers this story from
semaphore about Rhonda santis blew my
effing mind the video with the son in
red the black sun was made by his
campaign
they outsourced the video to a third
party and the dude who made it retweeted
they fired him through under the bus
this is the the the the anti-lgbt uh I
shouldn't call that the the video they
made criticizing Trump's stance on LGBT
issues made in-house outsourced so they
could have plausible deniability the the
the video in which Ron DeSantis is
appearing before a spiraling Nazi
sonenrad symbol with Soldiers with
soldiers marching towards it was made by
a camp by one of their I believe he was
a campaign staffer
and then
sent to a third party and retweeted and
we have it here check this out
the scoop senior aide to DeSantis
oversaw the campaign's high-risk
strategy of laundering incendiary videos
produced by their staff through Allied
Anonymous Twitter accounts a set of
internal campaign Communications
obtained by some of four reveals the
videos include two that have that have
created distract uh recurring
distractions for his campaign
check it out they say screenshots of the
war room chat reviewed myself before
included staffers praising a widely
derided and since deleted video
originally posted on an anonymous
account Ron DeSantis fan cams that
included a version of the son in rad a
symbol associated with Nazi Germany
quote this belongs in the Smithsonian
wrote Kyle lamb the campaign's director
of research and data before the video
blew up in the campaign's face he was
among the 38 staffers laid off in recent
weeks amid a campaign reset messages
viewed by semaphore also Show members of
the War Room group actively sharing
images to put in the video while it was
in the editing process though not the
Sun and red symbol that was in the final
version the big the big issue here that
I want to bring up to check it out the
campaign is never publicly confirmed or
denied ownership over the LGBT and sound
and red videos which staffers retweeted
after they were posted by Anonymous
accounts they recently fired one Aid
Nate Hockman who shared the latter video
and according to an axios report created
it
Tim cast has reached out this is a a
while ago to the Santa's campaign to
have someone come on the show for a
polite normal discussion and they refuse
I I was just thinking I think Ron needs
less social media presence but more
focused honest stuff but then I'm like
well why am I thinking that when I think
of Vivek ramaswamy I think more social
media more everything you're doing even
if they knock Trump out I don't think
DeSantis has a chance I mean after
everything his campaign is just crashing
and burning day by day worse and worse I
think Vivek is is the guy I mean if if
he steps up Vivek seems like a much more
optional candidate
here's the thing with a vague
someone will accuse him of something and
then he will outright address it or make
a statement and nobody else is doing
that I mean with the wef stuff with
everything he came out and then when
Trump was raided he came out and said
this is unprecedented we can't allow
this he's the only one doing that I'm
gonna I'm gonna tell you exactly what I
think by the Santa's campaign and uh I'm
sure I'm gonna piss off a lot of people
but I'm gonna say it anyway
I'll tell you what my view is
the the some Trump individuals I don't
know who or what the deal is posted a
photo of DeSantis team and there was a
picture of Christina Pasha with rug
burns on her knees as if to imply
something untoward about her
this is around the time this whole thing
got kicked off where all of a sudden the
Santa supporters just started rabidly
snarling and spitting in people's faces
I think she was emotionally slighted
triggered to the point where she started
using the DeSantis campaign as a vehicle
for emotional satisfaction against the
people who insulted her I think you're
completely right and the same thing
happened again when I think it was uh
Alex brusowitz here at least a picture
which was clearly a meme uh with push
paw and then it was George sorosity
Nixon which was clearly photoshopped
there was a picture where it was like in
the background yeah it was like a
clearly photoshopped George Soros it
wasn't even a good Photoshop and then
they just went rabid on everybody it
seems like and what happens is you've
got a handful of people who are like
Trump influences or whatever who played
dirty or whatever and so their their
response is to attack any and everyone
who dare insult them or even question
them in any way the fact that you know
what what we've seen with the reaction
you know Mike cernovich tweeting about
it how the DeSantis campaign has just
started attacking everybody
you know having talked to a few other
people not Mike but a few people about
what it is it seems that Christina Pasha
initially everybody were they were big
fans she was working with Santa she was
she was going for the media she was
calling out their BS and then this rug
burn knee thing happened and all of a
sudden it was just like
I I look I get it it's like really
insulting condescending demeaning
misogynistic whatever you want to call
it but that was the moment where it
seemed like something flipped and now
anybody who had a bad word to say was
just getting bitten was just getting
spat on and slapped around for it
doesn't matter they declared war after
that well and after this there's no way
that the DeSantis campaign can succeed
because you just marginalized and pushed
away all these people that are loyal to
Trump these people that yeah if Trump
gets knocked out they probably would
have voted for DeSantis but why would
they vote for him now when they've
essentially just been I mean hitting on
them over and over again there's this
like a pro de santis account that
appears to have like an AI deep fake
Avatar or whatever has been promoted Max
snored well that's that's got a Family
Guy character yeah but this one made a
like deep fake audio thing of me
praising Christina Bashaw and I'm just
like these guys have to be Trump
supporters because the only the only
outcome of doing something like that is
to try and get me angry so that I insult
the to Santa's campaign but I could but
uh and that's why I'm like this has got
to be a trump supporter you like make
that false flag DeSantis and trick them
into promoting things that hurt their
campaign or a Biden's supporter because
absolutely yup make sure Defenders can't
win but then I gotta tell you I gotta
tell you if Ron DeSantis won't fire
Christina peshaw it doesn't matter if
it's an intended to sink his campaign or
not the man cannot deal with his
campaign he cannot operate a campaign
it's good that he fired the people he
fired but I can tell you this I know
some of the people you fired should not
have been fired some of the people that
he fired he should have promoted and
fired the senior staff instead of he
laid off some like 38 people I know some
of them and I know they're smart and I
know they understand everything I'm
saying but they're the ones who got let
go Ron DeSantis in this capacity has
failed miserably and the person who's
led the charge the whole way as they've
just crashed and burned he won't fire
well their messaging is absolutely
terrible I mean they're keeping the
people that are like look at like Jeremy
Redfern I think that's his name right
after Ashley Babbitt was shot and killed
uh you know he came out essentially
praising it he said said f around and
find out and it's like the messaging
does not align with anybody that
supports Trump so how do you expect to
garnish these votes with keeping these
people on your campaign I think we're
learning something about Ron DeSantis I
think we're learning that he barely won
the first in the first place in Florida
Trump's support helped push them over
the edge how did he win so well I was
warning about this too everyone's saying
Rhonda Sanders is such a good leader
that he won by a million votes to a
certain degree I agree with that but I
also wanted to point out as I have since
the beginning you also had Mass Exodus
from many other states of right-leaning
people or more libertarian-leaning
people who went to Florida because of
the policy and were guaranteed to vote
in this direction and then people can
say yes but that was Rhonda Sanders's
leadership fair I agree
I will add however it was unobstructed
leadership because the legislature was
on his side so he had a clear path to
Rolling these things out when it comes
to a campaign he can't fire the people
who have failed
no every day it gets worse at this point
maybe he can recover I'm not saying he
can't but when you look at all the
polling data I can't remember who the
one one major polling agency said at
this point in a primary race no
candidate polling at these numbers has
ever been able to turn it around
I think his campaign sunken I don't
think there's any recovery into this
point it's it's it it it's it kind of
makes me sad one especially oh yeah well
especially after because I don't think
he did good in the uh in the Tucker
interview either where he was
interviewing the candidates he came off
as a neocon I mean he just seemed like
he was kind of a Warhawk throughout that
entire interview and seemed disingenuous
but then you know you have vivec and I
think he did the best out of anybody up
there he was honest the entire time and
his message resonated with people but
every other candidate and even DeSantis
I mean after I watched that I was off
the DeSantis train completely because I
was like I don't think this guy actually
believes in what he's talking about I
will I will say this because we got a
super chat this guy Nathan C says to
Santa's campaign is fine you guys are
projecting for sure I don't even believe
the story the video came from his
staffer any name proof yes Nate hochman
and I can confirm personally that I have
spoken with people within the
descendants descendants campaign and
Hawkman did make the video don't believe
me don't care I am telling you that's
where I'm at because I got on the phone
with people like come on we've been in
the space for a very long time we know
many of the people who went to work Ron
DeSantis in fact I have DMS with with
the people in his communication staff
and we'd invite him on the show before
but as soon as his campaign started they
win full corporate neocon locked down
told their people not to appear on this
show because we were critical of them
and I reached out and I said
did this guy do it
he did it
it's publicly known it's publicly never
fired the guy well they threw him under
the bus but but this is all publicly
known I mean this is in semaphore and
axios I don't believe it but look if
you're gonna sit there and be like this
is clearly not true it didn't happen yo
they deleted the video and fired the guy
like come on yeah sounds about right I
thought they did it sounds like a
leftist just denying basic reality at
this point and you know I I understand
loving Ron DeSantis and everything and
trying to back him as your candidate but
there's evidence on all of these things
there's there's uncountable evidence I
have a lot of faith that Ron would come
by the couple weeks after he started
announced and play ball like shoot some
hoops and then do the show for a couple
hours and it would have been awesome and
we'd see the real guy hear about his
family what his dreams are for the
future what he did before College all
that cool stuff that you want to know
about a guy if you're going to entrust
him with that kind of power to represent
you on the geopolitical stage but
unfortunately week three went by week
four went by week five went by they put
out that gross deep fake and and then
I've just kind of lost I have zero Faith
now in Rhonda well you look at the
difference too like socially wise
engaging not just with audiences on
stage but engaging with supporters and
fans of you Ron DeSantis is so awkward
in person when he does this he clearly
has no care in the world to engage he
doesn't have Charisma when he's engaging
with his fans he'll just say two things
and then he'll walk off and go do
something else but then Trump I mean
he's sitting there you know signing
Medal of Honor pictures going to fast
food restaurants buying people food he
resonates a lot more culturally yeah
Santa's was a VP pick DeSantis wanted to
be the big dog he should have been the
VP he could have been the VP to Trump he
could have been he could have been the
the the the the the easy going guy the
younger guy that would have helped
Donald Trump get the votes especially
from Suburban women and things like that
instead he says no I'm gonna be the guy
I'm not a number two guy
well now I don't think he's ever going
to be the guy even in Florida again I
mean at this point well I mean he turns
out yeah I mean he's he's going to be
done in politics I think I think this is
a career killer for DeSantis because you
try to take the helm from clearly who
was the nominee and there's no question
about it instead of just playing ball
and helping the country uh you know in a
state of I would say great need let's
jump to a with a hard segue to war
ladies and gentlemen from The New York
Times drone again hits a Moscow building
housing Russian Ministries this was in
the wee hours of the morning but you
know what I gotta admit I don't care all
that much because this is not the story
you should pay attention to
this is the story you should pay
attention to hey why don't you read that
Ian we need the subject says a limited
Military draft I just didn't want people
to say that I'm the one saying that
because I don't think we do
military.com we need a limited Military
draft we then have the Council on
Foreign Relations the uncertain future
of the US military's all-volunteer force
from July 18 2023 which concludes that
uh we're going to need a new gates
commission to figure out how we how we
deal with this
Joe Biden has called The Ready reserves
and select reserves to be deployed to
Europe
over what's what's going on in Ukraine
and this operation's been ongoing since
2014. Oliver Stone says he regrets
voting for Biden because Biden's leading
us into World War III you've now got and
it's not just these two op-eds more
calls for a military draft and you know
what the only thing I can say is I
really look forward to seeing Harry
sitting on the front lines making Tic
Tac videos yeah because they ain't
drafting the 37 year olds first well
don't be so Pie in the Sky man if if it
hits the fan we're all on the chopping
block no yeah yeah I know but what I'm
saying is it'll be a good year or so
before they draft a 37 year old over the
20 years what pisses me off is that
Biden gave that covid vaccine mandate
across the military a bunch of people
resigned or got kicked out and now
they're like trying to pull their pants
back up because they crapped their
diapers and like well in there
but I will add to that too and the
insane woke policy stuff there were a
bunch of things the Biden Administration
and million others had done which
decimated our our numbers forcing people
to to resign or just not want to enlist
at all
oh what were you gonna say moza did you
have something you were about to say too
oh well I was I mean you're not going to
send me to the draft I'll tell you that
right now I'm gonna die before I go
until before I'm 23. so I'm the prime
age right well but but you're not first
in line yeah not first in line for a few
months at the same time it's interesting
because they've purged all these you
know right-wing extremists from the
military they've really been focused on
that but those those guys are the guys
that are fit those guys are the guys
that are allegedly my my my friend
Taylor okay you're 23. yeah uh how tall
are you I'm six foot you're six feet
tall yep uh how much do you weigh 178
178 and uh you work out a lot yeah you
lift yes yeah do you think they're gonna
choose one of these uh soy boys little
five foot five weak noodle armed antifa
guys they're gonna be like I'm the I'm
the prime Canon but that's what I'm
saying I mean you're not gonna get me
you're not gonna get me regardless of
what you do I will die defending my
right not to go to war for the military
industrial complex especially in Ukraine
and we'll tell you that in 10 years it's
gonna be it doesn't it won't much matter
like the physical fitness of the person
because they're going to be piloting
drones and wearing super soldier
exoskeletons and stuff have you seen no
no you're not going to win they're not
going to wear why would you send a
person in it's mostly for Logistics well
and think about that area think about
the generations that have been raised on
video games too that's perfectly in
sight with the technology that the US
military uses that's literally what
they're prepping you for essentially and
granted I love video games but you're
exposed to the violence for a reason
you're exposed to you know doing drone
strikes on people for a reason because
you know they're they're basically
prepping and grooming this younger
generation into accepting War I used to
perform to Canada man my dad was sucked
into Vietnam and it annihilated pretty
much everything in his life you know
along with his cousin and God knows
however many members of that generation
he'd always tell me about the horror of
war in an unjust draft and I knew like
it was a dark fantasy of like what would
I do I'd have to I'd have to flee I'm
not gonna go die on some battlefield for
some oligarch I got too much to give to
this earth you're gonna for Joe Biden no
no no I'll defend this country I'm here
that's what the military is the future
of war is going to be those Boston
Dynamics robots the docks I mean we're
just terrible got it right they've
already mounted machine guns to those
dogs those little robots I think that in
biological warfare everybody talks about
nukes this nukes that why would you use
nukes when you can use something that is
essentially untraceable I mean you see
with the covid lab leak that's the
future it's not so much that it's a
nuclear weapon destroys the city yep but
we want the city we want the city we
want the resources we want the the coal
The Ore the uranium whatever honestly
want the Sevilla weapon and so we want
their civilians to be part of our
country
DNA you get the DNA of certain political
leaders and their families and you
engineer bio weapons that only target
them yep and then the virus can infect
tons of people and nothing happens but
then all of a sudden these particular
individuals just
yeah that was great that RFK actually
mentioned that although he did get taken
out of context but genetically
engineered bioweapons that take out
certain types of human didn't they say
that he was being an anti-semite because
of that clip yeah is that the clip that
they tried to accuse me
amplify it back at it he told the truth
oh he made a noise
yeah I I so you think that humans are
not gonna get like it's not gonna be as
human on human Warfare from above by
robots and like we'll just be watching
yeah I think sending in a wave of those
Boston Dynamics robots is look a nuclear
weapon will destroy the city we but we
want to own the city we want their
resources and we want to subjugate them
it may just be easier to unleash a virus
that targets a specific genetic profile
because we you sure you might want the
civilians but if you want to win the war
just erase the country well just like
that even if you go down like the the
physical you know human on human kinetic
route you're going to end with robots
and all these things right there's going
to be humans thrown in the meat grinder
yeah it's not going to be it's not going
to be robots on robots it's going to be
robots slaughtering humans
it's going to be machines well and not
just that it won't be just run by humans
yeah slaughtering us yeah there's no
there's no reason to wear an Exo Suit
the um did you ever see that short film
about drone Warfare it was just like 10
minutes about a guy giving a TED talk
about a drone or something like that and
like it's people running from building
to building trying to dodge these flying
drones with machine guns that are
killing anything that moves well you've
seen the videos out of Ukraine and
Russia I mean that they're drone Warfare
have you looked at have you seen any
Drone footage
they're scary they're they're not big
you can't even see them a lot of the
time flying alone here flying bombs yeah
targeting your GPS coordinates you see
dudes just like like like this like
begging begging not to drop the bomb and
they just drop it and then see there's
that one video they released where
there's a guy cowering in a foxhole yep
and then the Drone is pointing down and
you see the bomb just fall and then boom
and then the guy starts groaning and
like struggling moving again yeah well
and it's and those videos are I mean
they're everywhere I'm glad they're
everywhere they are everywhere but it
shows the realities of war and then
there was that one video of the
ukrainians I think it was like their
their trans Tifa force or whatever in
that Minefield and they all got their
legs
the guy jumps off the back of the truck
and he's just ready to land and kneel
and he lands on the on the thing well
then they go and try and help their
their friends you know that are down and
then they hit it the same thing too they
hit another mine I mean and the end of
it they all end up having I mean they're
missing limps dude the guy lands on the
landmine he gets his legs blown apart
and he immediately starts tourniqueting
himself like it's just horrific yeah
well and that's the thing is I think I
think the realities of War need to be
broadcasted but there's a reason why
they aren't any regular person sees any
of these videos It's Gonna discuss them
because frankly war is the most evil and
disgusting thing that you can do on this
entire planet I mean humans killing each
other for what for the idea that their
leaders are right and that the
international conflict is Justified I
don't think any International conflict
is Justified I mean when you have people
murdering each other because that's
exactly what this is there's I don't see
how anyone can say oh yeah I'm going for
Ukraine or I'm going for Russia no both
sides are at fault they're both
murdering people I understand resource
grabs like it's not good but if one
country doesn't have enough food and the
other one has more than enough and then
they're like coming and invading trade
works way better than War it does
but then you need a Common Language you
don't need one but it sure helps you
need a common culture in order to keep
sustained training you don't need it
history you know you said there's been
there's been cultures that were very
different have managed to trade with
each other and and remain very different
cultures and still live peacefully side
by side with each other simply put it
you don't have to keep killing this
Russian thing is about a port it's a
land grab because they they want a trade
route and you can't buy a trade route I
mean they technically could buy the land
off Ukraine for 700 trillion or whatever
whatever the value over the next 80
years where they need access to that
right yeah they need East 105 supporting
it over land that freeway down to Crimea
and and I don't know if there's anything
they could buy it you could sell it to
them but at this point it's just Rubble
I mean I don't know do you know much
about what's going on is the Don Bass
Just leveled is it just a mud field I
mean a lot of things were just
completely leveled over there it is
seriously there's a reason why there's
so many videos out there in these
especially telegram telegram is the
biggest distributor of these videos
that's where you really see the
uncensored stuff
um you put it on Twitter and even it
gets censored even on Twitter because
you're not supposed to see these things
I mean it's brutal it's the realities of
life and the realities of following
these dictators orders I mean and you
know I don't agree with Putin doing the
land room I don't agree with zielinski
casting out uh Catholics and Christians
I don't agree with any of this I think
everybody's in the wrong there's better
ways to go about I mean trade deals
right it's a perfect example you don't
have to kill each other just come to an
agreement come to a price and give each
other something that benefits both of
you that's the reality of how the world
is supposed to work but instead they'd
rather just murder each other because
that's where the money's at and it's sad
I mean it's truly heartbreaking
especially I have a lot of friends that
have come back from Iraq and the these
other war-torn countries and they went
there thinking they were bringing
democracy to these people and then they
get there they are told to dehumanize
these people they kill these people and
then they realize oh these people don't
want democracy they're literally openly
saying they don't want democracy this is
a different culture and then the guys
come back the VA doesn't take care of
them it's the most disgusting thing I've
ever seen they swap them providers and
then these veterans kill themselves
because they have to deal with the fact
that they were sent over to murder
people under the guise of restoring
democracy I want to jump to uh back to
politics because uh the vague ramaswamy
issued a statement three hours ago and
just announced he's filed a lawsuit
against the U.S Department of Justice
for a failure to respond to his foia
request to uncover what wise officials
including Joe Biden communicated to
Merrick Garland and Jack Smith about uh
let me read it about
um
uh about the unprecedented indictment in
the classified documents case of former
U.S president and one of Biden's
political opponents in the 2024
presidential election I'm also filing a
separate foia request with the doj to
uncover any similar Communications
relating to the just issued January 6
Trump indictment we should demand
accountability and transparency in USV
Alvarez Supreme Court held that
political candidates have First
Amendment right to knowingly make
inaccurate statements if you're going to
indent a former president and leading
presidential candidate it better not be
based on unprecedented precedented legal
Theory
further it's much more than a stretch to
call something criminal if someone is
seeking legal counsel from their own
lawyers Jack Smith has created a
dangerous precedent by criminalizing the
behavior of Trump's lawyers who offered
him legal advice labeling them
co-conspirators instead this jeopardizes
the future of our legal system if we
fail to admit the truth January 6 will
just be a preview of far worse to come
we must reunite this country but the
path forward will not be easy I want to
play the video uh I assume it's probably
a different statement but let's uh let's
play it it's another sad moment in our
country's history the 45th president of
the United States Donald Trump has yet
again been indicted by the Biden doj a
political party in power that is now
repeatedly using police force to indict
and arrest and potentially eliminate its
political opponents from competition
this is a politicized prosecution it is
a political persecution through
prosecution now in a third indictment
just in a matter of months against the
person who is still at present the lead
contender in the Republican primary for
U.S president
I want to be very clear I am running for
U.S president in that same Republican
primary it would be easier for me if
Donald Trump were eliminated from
competition that's not how I want to win
this is not about politics to me this is
about first principles we do not want to
become a country where the party in
power is able to use banana
republic-like tactics to eliminate its
political opponents
you know I'm sad to say that's exactly
where we are
the allegations in this indictment fall
flat it is wrong and Incorrect and
inaccurate to place blame for what
happened on January 6th at the feet of
Donald Trump
I said this at the time I've said it
ever since then I continue to say it
today
I would not have made the same judgments
that Donald Trump did in how he handled
that day
but that's different from saying that he
committed a crime he did not he
specifically told the protesters that
day to behave peacefully the first
amendment in this country gives
political protesters the ability to
express themselves and their opinions
freely
Donald Trump was not responsible for
what happened on January 6th you want to
know what was responsible I said this in
the days after January 6 2021 just as I
say it today
systematic pervasive censorship in this
country
that was after a year where we had told
people across this nation that you had
to stay locked down in your house in
your basement and shut up sit down do as
you're told if you question that you're
racist you're anti-science your social
media accounts were silenced you had to
stay home and lock down unless you were
part of BLM or antifa in which case it
was perfectly fine to roam the streets
of this country and burn many of them
down
that was the double standard that then
applied and said that if you said the
virus originated in a lab in Wuhan you
were again a racist and had your
internet accounts shut down you were
then told you had an election where you
could express yourself to put the right
person in charge of fixing these
problems and instead your accounts were
suppressed if you sent a mere message
saying that the hunter Biden laptop
stories from the New York Post was real
you had your accounts locked even the
New York Post had its own account logged
and if you repeatedly then tell people
they cannot speak that is when they
screen if you repeatedly tell people
they cannot scream that is when they
tear things down and I think we are
making a grave mistake in this country
by trying to pin the blame for that at
the feet of one man
if we refuse to learn our mistakes from
from our mistakes in the past we are
doomed to suffer an even worse fate in
the future I worry that will create a
country where January 6 2021 was a
friendly parlay compared to what's
actually to come I'm running for
president to make sure we don't March
towards some kind of national divorce
but the first and most important step
that we as candidates can take in this
race is to speak and speak forcefully on
the side of principle to say that even
if we're competing against Donald Trump
as I am I do not want to see him
eliminated from competition using these
politicized tactics it is wrong for our
country it is wrong for our future I
call on my fellow candidates to condemn
it and I call on President Biden to do
the right thing and drop these
politicized charges that's going to be a
first step towards uniting our country
so did uh just uh step into second place
in the Republican primary yes dude I
hope so holy smokes that was that was
really well done he did the exact same
thing I mean not the exact same thing
when uh the Mar-A-Lago raid happened I
mean this guy is a winner right here and
you where's Rhonda Santos's video
where's that at where is him condemning
this I mean I'm not gonna you know I I
I'll try and avoid comparing him let's
just like that was a very very well done
video that's professional he's just
talking to the camera I don't think
there's a script there I mean I'm just
looking at all something the whole
production and I'm like this guy knows
part way through I was like I got to see
him and Obama get together and talk
geopolitics because this guy is the
president this is the guy he is the
right wing version of Obama but I think
he's actually actually genuine I think
that's the big difference but the way
that he is able to word things it's a
talent I mean he is very gifted he's a
businessman just like Trump is he's an
outsider and I can see why people see
him as a threat what else he is his
family is Indian and I don't I'm not big
into identity politics but you want to
talk about an ally in the 21st century
India it's the United States and India
if you're concerned about China it feels
and communism you want India India is
the final piece of that if India sides
with the Communist Party Asia is a
deafening Roar if India and the United
States are Allied that could be one of
the most powerful peace bringing uh
unions in the world totally here yeah
Trump uh had a meeting was it Modi at
the time and Trump they love Trump but
vivek's an American citizens no his
parents were born in India I know but he
was born yeah but as I said it's his
parents he's got India Heritage his
parents were from India and I'm not into
the identity stuff A white guy from
South Dakota could be a better Indian
Diplomat you know than Vivek but his
parents are India I'll tell you he's
Hindu like this is a good opportunity to
Bridge and blend some gaps I've had
people say they don't trust him or
whatever but I'm like the dude sat down
in front of me and outright said he
thinks there should be some kind of
Civic test for people to get the right
to vote amazing and I'm just like I
agree with you we've talked about that
on the show but the idea that someone
running for office would say something
like that that's like
every advisor to be like no no no don't
say that because you're gonna lose
you're going to lose voters in this
demographic or that demographic and he
was like sits back and he's like I don't
know they'll probably get mad at me for
saying this but we got to have some kind
of uh test or or qualifier for voting in
this country I love the fact that he's
at least thinking about the
ramifications of an ignorant population
being manipulated by
you know social media companies
corporations the government itself
whatever I love the fact that he's like
look people are going to be manipulated
to some degree so we need to do what we
can to make sure that the people that
are voting actually care about voting
because I've honestly I truly believe
that there are far more people that will
get upset if you tell them that we're
going to take away the right of your
your right to vote then we'll go out and
vote right like there are way more
people that are like I want the right
even though I have never and will never
get my ass off the couch and go out and
the simple idea that anybody can vote is
actually absurd the fact that you don't
have to take just a simple civics class
so you can at least prove that you know
the bare minimum about government yeah
people that you're voting in is insane
to me I don't know how and I so I'm not
going to make a prescription as to the
way to
ensure that the people voting and not
only have a stake and and and have
actual uh you know concern about the the
policies and stuff Beyond just voting
for you know to put their hands in the
government's Pockets
um but
the idea that you need to have some kind
of qualification or at least prove that
you have that you care about where the
country's going not not just
you care about being able to stick your
hand in the government's coffers I think
that's something that's worth talking
about let's take a look at the betting
odds here it's from Real Clear Politics
RCP betting average and you can see
ramaswamy since he entered has just been
climbing and climbing and climbing he's
currently at 14 cents in the prediction
markets Donald Trump has seen a major
spike but interestingly when they
started tracking this in January Ron
DeSantis was in the lead
that means if you were to have bought
shares on the prediction Market of Ronda
Sanders in January you'd have lost
you're hurting you're you're you I mean
you're we're talking 80 of of of your of
your bet
even Donald Trump improved but but I
think ramaswamy
I think you know we've already seen him
tie in some polls for a second and we've
seen in the prediction markets he's tied
for a second I think I think you give it
a week especially with this statement
Scott Adams just tweeted something like
is it just me or he did he do that
without notes there was that one point
where he accidentally forgot to say the
word from and then quickly caught it I
noticed that and I'm like he doesn't
have a script yeah when I heard that I'm
like there's no script there you see how
well spoken he is a guy like this
doesn't need a script
he said if we don't learn our mistakes
if we don't learn from our past mistakes
so he misspoke the word right well it's
from it makes you believe he's more
genuine because he's not going off a
script like every one of these other
politics unless he's so smart he has a
prompter but he intentionally he talked
to me like that seven years old yeah the
guy's amazing dude he's very got that I
don't know Obama Fuller than me I like I
almost want him to like join the unit
party just to get in so that he can
become the brilliant Visionary and
alterator that we need but I I don't
want to see him get lost to the universe
but that's what happens when you become
president you become the leader of the
military industrial complex and he's
willing he knows he's going to get
changed he said that to you Tim on the
culture War he's like I'm gonna go in
there I'm gonna be a different person
after eight years I know I'm willing I
was saying that I thought
he could not win Trump's the clear
front-runner Trump will be the nominee
at this point I'm thinking like Vivek
has has defended the right principles
he's defended Trump he's spoken clearly
and truthfully and honestly he's
addressed every question put before him
I'm extremely impressed with him and I
think I think he's in second place
like the polling's gonna come out but I
think he's in second place I think that
for a lot of trump supporters if Trump
is forcefully removed from the ballot to
the point where there is no choice
a lot of these guys are going to vote
for ramaswamy
yeah even Trump likes them Trump's
spoken very highly of him and and at
this point with that I'm like I could
see him being VP if if he said he didn't
want to do it they all say that they do
you have to say you don't want to yeah
otherwise they'll just I mean that's
that's what I was talking about earlier
I think he'd be the perfect VP for Trump
the perfect person to level Trump out
you know almost defense but much better
significantly better in every single way
and he's Hindu so Christians will
support him I mean there's a lot of
parallels between these as long as
they're religious they have basic values
you're going to get the votes I feel
like he like Vivek will just make social
media posts non-stop as VP if he was VP
and just piss Trump off so bad because
he's got different ideas although
Trump's a listener like Trump has a
really good memory that's I think one
really good quality about him is a great
memory and he's a good listener
apparently he seems like a very good
listener I think he would benefit
greatly from having somebody like vivec
with him because he can I mean you'd see
in his past administration he had bad
people around him and those bad ideas
were reflected a lot through his
administration but you put someone like
Vivek around him these ideas are good
ideas yeah granted not all of them are
but he has better ideas than almost
anybody I've I mean I would argue this
is the best candidate that I relate to
more on a personal level I wonder if
anyone I wonder if a vague's real
strategy is uh
is auditioning for the role of VP I
think so I do think so but think about
it trumps doesn't care who you are Trump
Trump's the kind of guy who's run
multiple businesses Vivek runs runs a
business right up to a half a million
dollars or multi-billion dollars he's a
guy who knows how you get the job and
I'm wondering if a fake is like you
can't go and apply to bvp you can't look
up to Trump say trust me just trust me
no no you get out there you prove it
Trump's seen it Trump likes him this
race will happen the vague handles
everything masterfully defends Trump
masterfully and then when it comes time
down to the primary Trump wins Vivek
Smiles shakes his hand and Trump says I
think you're the guy
I think that's I think that's the
honestly the only road map for Trump to
win as well I think if Trump picks just
about anybody else I don't think there's
really a possibility for him to reach
other voters that he wasn't able to
reach before I mean granted his votes
are going to go up because of the
economy and everything else but vivec is
the guy to Garner those votes that he
wouldn't regularly obtain we're gonna go
to super chats if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share this
show with your friends post that URL if
you can if you really do like the show
it really helps and head over to
timcast.com click join us to become a
member and watch the members only
uncensored show which will be live
tonight at about 10 or so p.m and we
will even take calls from you our
members you got to be a member for at
least six months or sign up at the 25
per month level it's a small screening
process we have to try and keep
nefarious actors out and we do have
screening press for the questions but uh
join us let's read what you got to say
all right Rick K says I would love to
see a program that requires teenagers to
work on a farm for 40 hours for
graduation it would benefit the country
as a whole and teach younger Generations
about agricultural animal husbandry
self-reliance completely agree you look
at the farm kids that grow up they're
always great I would say a month
yeah for one month you go and and stay
on a farm and you do General farm work
once you start getting up early I mean
that's that's training and it's a work
ethic too that's what makes men and
that's what makes people I mean you look
at the farm kids right they always end
up more right wing they always end up
holding their values and not straying
away from them hard work is what
ingrains people to have good morals I
genuinely believe in that and even with
sports football baseball all these
American Sports it's not about the sport
it's about the values that you teach
through those Sports three months yes no
that's too long I don't know three
months is a season you have to be there
at least out of seven kids yeah yeah of
course man yeah yeah in order to
graduate Public School geez in order to
graduate you have to actually do
something about within the real world
because farming isn't just picking
grapes or something no it is there's
Financial elements to it there's the
shipment's coming in at six a.m it's
real world training if the crops fail so
do you and look we're not saying you
work 30 hours you know uh 24 hours a day
30 hours a day I'm exaggerating you you
work an eight-hour shift just a farm
hand you just exactly you work eight
hours a day like a new normal job you
basically just have for three months a
summer job right that's it that's what
I'm thinking a summer job for three
months yeah and you get paid I think
they should get paid a stipend and then
once the summer is over they'll be like
I went on the summer the summer camp and
I worked a summer job yeah whoever sent
that super chat's a real one then when
when you get out you've learned a whole
bunch about how the farm Works about how
Finance shipments delivery packaging you
learn where the the product is going you
make money so when you leave you'll have
a couple brand new but I graduated my
school I got a couple Grand I put in my
bank account I'm off to a good start
that's a great idea that the Rockefeller
school system it's designed the way it
is for a reason right it's for factory
workers yeah
wake up too early before your brain's
fully functioning I mean we see it over
and over again but that would
significantly not just fix the school
system but fix the values in this
country that's right it's the answer to
factory farming like yeah literally is
yeah there's something beneficial not
sitting in a factory all day all right
no just abolish the partner of Education
let's read some more we got Raymond g
Stanley Junior says Tim I liked Pasha at
first a lot of spit and fury she was
fiery but mostly peaceful now she's
basically the female version of Brooklyn
dad
yeah I've kind of been not uh not
looking at her much because I I still
have faith or hope that she'll come on
the show or Ron will come on the show
maybe but well and see I I agree with
him I really liked Pusha she had a lot
of potential she was handling the media
masterfully and then all of a sudden I
mean that that picture comes out with
her red knees and next thing you know
it's just Hellfire over and over again
from her in the Santa's campaign all
right Goldilocks says Trump getting hit
with this charge is like Clinton
deleting emails of documents she
shouldn't have had both situations are
bullet and shouldn't have been be
happening them charging Trump is going
to be bad for the unity of America
completely agree The Bag Man says world
war three will happen so Trump will lose
2024 election and we'll all go to the
Dark Ages I have never been wrong in my
life well all right good luck sir
Skylar Pearson says Tim your voice is so
Dynamic that deep fake of you sounded so
flat and uninteresting like a 1980s talk
show host version of you yeah we were
talking about this uh like if you put
the Joe if you put Joe Rogan in that
voice deep fake thing it Nails it and
it's weird there's a few other people
that it really gets but for some reason
it just does not get in my voice you do
a lot of different tones when you speak
I think that's the biggest thing is your
your tone changes and your demeanor
changes consistently through your
sentences so it's harder for AI to track
that but he's just flat it's hard to
impersonate Joe Rogan but the AI seems
to get him
you know what do I do that uh you know
kind of talk like that it's hard to get
yeah he doesn't have like the thrill the
eye version of him doesn't have a thrill
to his voice Donald Trump had he's
nasally yep so you have to push your
tongue up against the back of your mouth
to get that nasally when you're talking
right and there's there's certain
characteristics of like Dr fauci that
you can just hone in on you don't need
to be wearing two masks but definitely
exaggerate two is a you don't need to so
two I can hear like Trump trump was hard
for me to figure out for a while I don't
think it's particularly super good or
whatever I just got some of the
characteristics your Nancy Pelosi one's
my favorite but that one's intentionally
insulting Donald Trump is it disgusting
it's meant to you know but uh uh like
with Joe Rogan I cannot figure out how
to speak that way it's just like it's
not it doesn't exist in the realm of
whatever my my shows yeah he's got like
a jovial kind of like no no it's like
the sound of his voice and the way he
speaks it's just like in the back of the
impossible for me to get and I've seen a
lot of cartoons like uh where they try
to impersonate Joe and they just make
him talk like this and I'm like Joe
doesn't talk he's got like a Boston
accent that's been kind of muted maybe
that has something to if you want to
catch it
all right let's grab some more Super
chats
all right Hank Fett says if they are
successful in getting Trump off the
ballot and run unopposed do you think
anyone on the right among his supporters
or the Republicans will do anything to
oppose it or is it over for us yeah I
think it's I think everything just falls
apart you gotta use different systems
but fighting that thing that oligarchy
is not the way I I can't imagine they
actually removed Trump from the ballot
because it's unprecedented and who does
it leave on the battle are they going to
eliminate the Republican party from the
ballot in all these different states it
would be Vivek and maybe he would win
and become the greatest president of all
time I don't know
I don't know man
I don't know could you imagine if Trump
said vote Vivek that would be crazy
I mean I suppose if if he got if he got
arrested I can't imagine a context where
Trump would do that I mean I think I
think the ego is a little bit too big
with Trump even if he is arrested and
died at everything I mean I think he's
still gonna say you're they robbed me
right he'd be like write me in and then
so that if you write me in then I can
pardon myself when I get in that would
that would be the thing I can't imagine
Trump being like Oh yeah you should
totally vote Max Reddick says Tim I know
that you have known David Pacman for a
long time you should ask him to come on
IRL and discuss Biden and the quid pro
quo oh God uh here's my prediction uh I
like David I've known for a long time
he's cool I think he's wrong about a lot
of things uh I think I also think that
he sometimes intentionally lies I think
if he came on the show it would
literally be just him saying like I
didn't know that I didn't know that I
didn't know that over and over and over
again
so like by all means we can invite him
on the show but you know I'll give you
an example he had a video clip where
um
there was a question asked of Ted Cruz
do you think that Ukraine interfered in
the U.S elections I think that's what it
was and Ted Cruz says something the
effect of like the New York Times
reported that they did and so did
Politico magazine and then you hear a
producer bust out laughing at him on on
NBC with like it like checked out or
something and then David Pacman starts
laughing as well and I'm like
did you Google this because the New York
Times Did report that Ukraine interfered
in the U.S election and Politico did
report that so it's not a question of
whether I believe like I don't know that
Politico reported do you agree with
Politico do you think they're lying
like are that political or your boys but
now they aren't
but so if David Pacman's response to
like a fact-based news report from a
liberal-leaning publication is to laugh
at them
I can only just say like he doesn't know
what's going on at all and if he does he
doesn't care yeah that's the reality the
point of the Laughing was to
delegitimize it wasn't that it wasn't to
address right but that implies David
Pacman is willfully manipulating his
audience to help Democrats win yeah yeah
absolutely yes I guess I like him I mean
I think he's kind of a a normal guy that
cares a lot about politics the normal
guy that lies a little bit too much I've
never seen him lie directly I'll send
you personally but uh okay if you yeah
if he lies then you know so be it but I
would still well it's been 15 years
coming David get over here it'd be a
better show for the culture War podcast
you know we'll invite him out but I'll
also say this like
David hosts his own show it is very
difficult and to a certain degree
unreasonable to ask someone hey stop
doing your Daily Show to come do mine
instead it's like oh come on it's not
fair you gotta hit a grand slam if he's
gonna come by which we got to figure
something out there
but if they if he wants to come on uh
you know Hassan as well culture War show
would be fantastic
I mean 100 feet a year you gotta
manifest that he will well
I'll be completely honest like the
reason Hassan won't come on this show is
because he doesn't know enough about any
of this stuff right he just acts like he
does and his audience eats it up yes yes
and uh David pakman I I genuinely
believe David Beckham might actually
come on the show Kyle Kolinski would for
sure do it towels are a good dude I
really like Kyle kolinsky uh he would
definitely come on the show it's just
with Kyle we've talked to him before and
it's like he's like hey I host Mountain
kind of busy but we'll try and find time
to make it work I'm like that'd be so
cool we're fans uh but it's funny
because you know Kyle's a lefty guy uh
Jimmy Dore is a lefty guy Jimmy Dore of
course is very anti-establishment but
there's no issue with getting these
honest actors when they're like Jimmy
Dore is wrong about some stuff totally
cool I I love Jimmy and uh Kyle cleanse
he's great but they're just like yeah
I'd love to come out we try and find
time to make it work these other guys
who are duplicitous are always just too
busy and just can't make it work it's
weird how that works it's the guys that
are honest but maybe wrong and their
views are willing to discuss them but
the guys that are dishonest and they
know that they're obviously wrong in
their views and that they can't answer
the questions when you know pushed about
it they're never going to come on let's
read some more powder pz says Tim I said
it when I called in a few weeks ago this
will be the last election
I don't know let's say that like
an election happens and 2024 and it's
hard to know whether it is actually an
election like when we say election we
mean free and fair and two candidates
argue and then the people make the
decision and we don't feel like 2024 is
going to be like that if Trump wins
there will be an election in 2028. yeah
they'll claim the voter rolls if Trump
wins they clean the voter rolls they
clean up election security you vote on
Election Day as per the Constitution one
person one vote Etc all that stuff
happens and then election happens just
like normal 2028. if Joe Biden wins
however I'm not so sure what happened I
feel like they're setting us up for a
one world government and they're like we
cannot let go of the power right now I
mean you look at the U.N agenda you see
all the One World governments on the
23rd it is coming into fruition
absolutely the U.N and that's part
that's part of what the whole uh um what
cbdc that's part of the reason why they
they want to have a CBD cbdc so that way
they can control the money because they
the the
ngos like the UN the uh wef
um the international international
monetary fund and stuff like that they
would like to see the governments of
Europe and the United States the West
have far more control over the people
and they would eventually they would
like to see a One World Government I
mean and that's always been the plan
it's almost been the plan since day one
Travis Delaney says Vivek was on David
Pacman today and Vivek called him out
for making lazy arguments
all right so he just keeps getting
better and better I was literally
driving to when I was driving in today I
was listening to Vivek and uh
but it was Adam and sich U great show
those guys are great yeah how did it how
did it seem should we should we check it
out well I mean it was how long was it
well it's like oh with Adam and sich
their stuff is usually multiple hours so
I mean like do you know how long vivekan
Pacman's thing was I don't know no I'd
imagine it's probably decently I also
was on Adam and Stitch's show I called
him Adam and Stitch yeah sorry buddy
it's sich like situation yes now you
know let's read some more
let's grab what do we got waffle sense
it says only three indictments I want my
president to have 100 indictments when
we elect him in 2024. it will be bigly I
mean at this rate you might get that
honestly careful what you wish for okay
let Sam finkman freed out they dropped
one of his charges yep Iggy the incubus
says let's say none of the law fair
stops Trump they already shattered
precedent by indicting him assassinating
presidents is more normal for these
people yeah but as much as like rfk's
mentioned that we're we're well beyond
that because we've talked about it quite
a bit they they canonize they make
Martyrs of these people and so physical
assassinations have gone away except for
the most extreme circumstances like you
know say Libya or or Iraq now it's all
about destroy someone's character so
that no one can look up to what they
propose they also do subtle stuff like
heart attack gun the CIA working on that
they don't want it to look like an
assassination plane crash I mean it's
very easy with the technology we have
now to make any death look like an
accident Alex Jones was saying he was
afraid that it would be Trump would go
down on a plane crash well I mean and
I'm still waiting for I mean there's
that one Simpson scene man where you got
Trump in that coffin and his you know in
his famous suit uh I feel they're right
pretty consistent a little dirty about
this man because Donald I don't you
don't deserve this kind of crap dude me
talking about fantasizing about all that
no man you do you dude all right Kyle
Miller says I find it funny that Tim
thinks Harry Chris or any Tick Tock for
Biden is going to be drafted I'm sure
they will be exempt from it I completely
disagree you know what these guys are
expendable media uh uh uh spots their
foot sold they exist to sell the
Democratic party if they don't get
drafted it damages The credibility of
the machine the machine will sacrifice
these guys in two seconds to sell a
draft and they will make them do it with
smiles on their faces you'll get a video
of Harry and Chris wearing their melty
uniforms being like we're doing the
right thing for our country why aren't
you and they're gonna be filming tick
tocks being deployed in the plane
they're gonna be like this is what it
means to fight for your country and
believe in America well any you know
they probably will never see combat
right but it's just going to be the
Ukraine situation with the the girls you
know in there and same with like the IDF
in Israel they always post the videos of
these girls fully kitted out or they're
dancing things like that to make it more
appealing like oh this is what war is
and they're gonna be the propaganda Tick
Tock guys of the war exactly
all right let's see what we got here
Nathan C says I think the Santa's
campaign is doing great did you see
Trump's small audience in Erie PA this
week no but if descendence's polls
tanking his donors bailing and them
laying off a bunch of staff is doing
great then I got a bridge to sell you
and a sonogram video I think yeah I
don't think he's doing so great yeah
that's crazy I think that that's the the
nail in the car yeah no wait it was the
son and Freud isn't it you said Sonic
Graham no sonograd Sonic that's what it
was okay sonograd
there it is
we will grab more Super chats
Jim Hansen says six years as an Army
Ranger five deployments to Afghanistan
no matter how much Tech you think you
have you always need a human with a
rifle and grenades to seize territory
you always need the meat grinder if he
has a line on my AIDS please let me know
drones can't drones can't occupy street
corners yeah exactly and that's that's
the important thing
what do we got here wrath says Grand
thumb YouTube channel did a video where
they tested the Drone Warfare scene in
Ukraine they are veterans and share some
interesting views you should you should
have him on he is awesome yeah he's very
outspoken thumb right now but he he is
genuinely amazing and he's recently
started to come out and say you know
what is a cancelable offense I mean
about everything going on I think he'd
be an awesome guest yeah he's very smart
yeah let's go around it's spelled
Grantham here and I know it's current
that I want Garen it's referring to the
Snapback
yeah because it snaps and hits your
thumb yeah he has a video where he's
testing it and he allows himself like 10
times yeah I have one of those dude it's
got balls of steel you know it don't
feel good no that's never happened we
should definitely have that guy on I
don't know him but I know people that
know him yeah back in the days when they
had clips and not magazines that's right
yeah people people still say clip and
not magazine I've done that a couple
times back in the day
what do we got Timothy Bond says have
y'all talked about the illegal lab they
found in California with covid mice no
he didn't but yeah they found a Chinese
bio lab in California we mentioned it
last night lovely Chinese I didn't know
you were referencing that what yeah when
did that happen
recently but it was it's been here for
at least you know a year a couple years
or something like that I don't know
they're testing covet on mice all right
okay tall Swiss says I'm seeing this
projecting smear attempt recently
increasing recently increasingly more by
the left you know the left is tactic of
accusing your opponent that of which you
are guilty of nice try loser and I think
that's a reference to the dude who said
we were projecting because uh you know
or whatever yeah you guys are projecting
DeSantis campaign is is crumbling he
laid off a ton of people they over hired
they've got all this negative press it
is not going well the polls are tanking
it's just it's unfortunate man it's
crazy how quickly he just out the gate
was on top and then he was on fire and
now on fire you're on fire but not in a
good way yeah he was on fire and now his
campaign's on fire
that's crazy yeah the O-ring fell off
the uh
campaign
in reference to Vivek Fire Sky says and
now he went up by 35 points
Raymond's G7 Junior says Vivek is team
forward the line
the Vic's great man well and as this
video gets more views too I mean because
this is the first day it's been out it's
been out for a few hours it's only going
to keep going up I'm pretty confident
that if uh Vivek were the nominee I
would vote for him yeah 100 I would 100
vote for him if he was comfortable
Nathan C says DeSantis responded today
to the indictment as president I will
end the weaponization of government
replace the FBI director and ensure A
single standard of Justice for All
Americans just the direction just the
director because we saw how great that
works out to be fair ifake didn't say he
would remove anybody and so it's like
okay I can respect it but like it's more
it's more than just that right The
Descendants campaign is having a bunch
of critical errors I want DeSantis to
succeed we want more competition in this
primary field and DeSantis has got a
great record in Florida but if his
supporters keep ignoring all the
problems plugging their ears and saying
la la everything's fine then you lose
and and fine go ahead I don't care yo
I'll say it again DeSantis needs to fire
Christina Pusha like I'm just I'm
flabbergasted he's not getting rid of
this person who's flubbed everything I'm
interested to see if she she responds to
these clips that come
and I'm just like I I avoided saying
anything I said it a little bit when the
Deep big thing happened and now it's
just like after reading the semaphore
piece where she's in this chat she's the
rapid response director and there they
put out the some of these videos they
put the Deep fake video their their team
she knows what's going on are they just
firing everyone around her for some
reason she's clearly doing a bad job
absolutely and Jeremy Redfern he's but
he's he's not even with the campaign
he's uh I think the he's in the
governor's uh staff in Florida yeah he
got moved positions but then you also
have Brian Griffin you have these
communications people that are just
burning the whole thing of the ground
and the scientist is like this is fine
well you got you got Trump saying Ashley
Babbitt was murdered and then you have
one of the Santa's number one guy saying
she f'd around and found out so there's
a huge disparity of uh communication
when I reached out to Redfern and said
are you guys really standing by this
deep fake he said something about it
being like it's just a meme yeah well
that's it there's in regards to burning
the campaign down there's one way to do
it is setting the fire yourself
Christina you obviously didn't do that
another way is if you're in the building
and it's burning around you and you just
sit there and don't do anything about it
you're essentially no she said you may
not be the one burning it down I think
you're allowing it to burn down she said
she's at the fires whether or not you
did if you're found there I I I
genuinely think it would take a rug burn
picture yeah it was that and then the
George Soros one is really what tipped
it over into full-blown just attack
everybody just just look at like Twitter
search X searches I guess now but
there's a lot of personalities saying
that she began attacking allies and
friends and like around this time damn
and it's like we we had been speaking
with her about coming on the show she
said yes you'd love to do in the future
we're big fans of DeSantis we want to do
an interview with him and then all of a
sudden one day she's just attacking me
on Twitter man you know and it's
interesting you wonder if there's any
you know like third party influencer
because she used to be the girl she used
to be the person that stood up to the
media that really just laid it down and
everybody loved her everybody's sharing
clips of her it's always going viral she
was another version of basically Kaylee
McKinney she was awesome and then now
all of a sudden complete flip-flop so
you wonder if there's any uh you know
third-party influence in that video guy
says Trump has a video response out
we'll we'll what we'll do is in the
members segment we'll uh we'll jump to
the video and then we'll we'll start
addressing inside we got a couple more
minutes we'll read a couple more Super
chats
all right Noah Sanders says did you see
that jenk was on the Patrick Bet David
podcast I love how he's more afraid of
Tim and you all than he is of Patrick
Bet David yuger PBG was he talking about
intercourse with horses again I know he
probably likes to do that I hope so I I
I'll solve that reference I think the
issue with uh uh like pbd isn't it's
like an entrepreneurial entrepreneurial
podcast it's not overtly political but
they talk politics this is a political
show where we do nothing but read the
news and we pull up sources for all of
our stories whenever we launch a story
I'm like here's the article from this
source and we always use News Guard
certified sources despite the fact that
News Guard is heavily criticized by the
right we do it for that reason this is
the reason why they don't want to come
on this show because what we say is
backed by their institutions and their
sources we're not making it up they
can't rebutt it yeah if it's framed as a
show where you're gonna go in and get
talked to about politics you're not
familiar with I understand why people
are like well I'll do that when I'm
ready well I mean you see how the
service guy did on here and if if Jen
comes on the show and says it's not true
Biden didn't do this and I play the
video yeah how is he gonna go back on
his show and maintain the LIE he can't
he'll lose followers he'll lose money
they can't Dana should come on she's
been pretty vocal she's fed up with
nonsense right now it's actually that's
been interesting watching her character
development because it does actually
seem genuine you know she's she's more
so straying and she's getting strong
from it there was dudes that actually
put their hands on her and that was the
what so and the reason the thing that
like initiated yeah this is Yeah Anna
kasparians
um she was walking her dog and there
were two dudes that were that looked
like they were homeless dudes outside of
her house or something like that and one
when she bent over or something like
that to do something to grab the dog or
whatever and one of the dudes walked up
behind him and basically did the whole
like you know pelvic thrust and then
they kept walking nothing happened to
her after that but it's like she was
like okay this is now actually come home
the problem of homeless people around
and oh wow and lawlessness has actually
she understood that the policies that
she was promoting in turn it actually
affected her for once yeah that was her
wake up one it seemed like and it's not
just that though there's other things
that she's that that was the first thing
but then there were other things where
she would she felt like people on the
left were gaslighting her about things
and she went and she looked into the
into Kyle Rittenhouse stuff and realized
that she had been ADV like actively
telling people things that were
completely wrong and she's had a kind of
an Awakening where she's like I didn't
know that I was wrong you know and that
speaks volumes when one of the one of
the more influential voices on the left
not only has come out and said hey I was
wrong with this this and this but I was
spreading this as if it was real and now
she's getting attacked ruthlessly by
tons of people on the left personally I
feel bad for Anna getting the for being
the recipient of the attacks but I'm
glad to see the left behaving the way
that they normally behave exactly well
uh maybe we'll see if she's willing to
come on the culture War podcast that'd
be great we'll set it up all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and become a member by
going to timcast.com clicking join us
the members only show will be starting
in a few minutes on the front page and
you don't want to miss it we're going to
pull up Trump's response and then talk
more about this and then take calls from
you you can follow the show at
timcastirl you can follow me personally
everywhere at timcast follow me on X and
Instagram I put up a skate video the
other day and uh yeah Taylor do you want
to shout anything out yeah just follow
me at Taylor USA it's
t-a-y-l-e-r-us-a on Twitter that's the
platform that I use the most and uh you
know Instagram's USA underscore Taylor
I am uh Phil that remains on Twitter or
X if you're uh the kind of you know
Cutting Edge person uh Phila remains
official on Instagram the band is All
That Remains available on Spotify Apple
music Pandora the YouTubes you know the
places and I mean Crossing if you're
watching it's right here behind me at
Ian Crossing anywhere on social media if
you're listening it's phonetic or maybe
it's not but find me on the internet
somewhere anywhere hit me up on X hit me
up on mines I love you guys great
conversation Taylor always a pleasure
man absolutely we're gonna get you
jacked we sure are thanks for the
inspiration Twitter about working out
that's uh building muscle so let's keep
it up
and move on yeah uh this is good seeing
you as well Taylor always a pleasure
always and uh I am gonna continue to
call it Bird app I am at surge.com I
hope to see you guys there be fun to
argue are you gonna call it letter app
no no no no I'm not gonna call letter
wrap forever we will see you all over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out